[Musique]
Isabelle Saporta, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bah voilà, je m'appelle Isabelle
Saporta. Je suis auteur, je suis
journaliste, je suis éditrice.
J'ai écrit pas mal de bouquins sur
l'agroalimentaire.
Euh le livre noir de l'agriculture, Vin
Business, euh Foutez-nous la paix. Euh
généralement à chacune des sorties de
mes bouquins, j'ai le droit à un procès,
hein, euh d'un lobby en place. Euh
voilà, là celui-là, écoutez, j'ai décidé
de m'attaquer à la caste en fait qui est
cette espèce de technructure un peu
délirante qui gouverne la France. Et
j'avoue que euh le comment dire
l'accueil euh est un peu harde de la
part de la technructure mais enfin je
m'y attendais donc voilà je suis pas
mécontente en fait.
Un peu hard dans quel sens ?
Bah c'est que si vous voulez à partir du
moment où vous vous attaquez à cette
cette caste, à cette technure au fond
ils vous disent voilà vous êtes
poujadiste, c'est du complotisme,
c'est faux en fait. Tout va très bien
madame la marquise. Sauf qu'il y a un
moment soit on y va, on décrit comment
ça se passe dans ce petit monde et en
fait on donne ça à voir à tous nos
concitoyens pour pour qu'enfin on soit
tous conscients que ça marche comme ça.
Soit effectivement on se trouve une
petite niche dans la caste. Il se trouve
que moi ça m'intéresse pas et que je
pense que démocratiquement on est en
train de mettre la France à genou parce
que les Français ont tout à fait
conscience que ça marche pas quoi. Ça
fonctionne pas. que c'est plus possible.
Et donc je ne vois pas tellement ce
qu'attendent nos gouvernants en fait.
Ils passent leur vie à nous dire que ils
ont très très peur qu'il y a un pouj qui
soit élu au pouvoir et en fait ils
passent leur vie à leur faire la courte
échelle. Donc euh donc voilà. Donc je
pense que soit on met les mains dans la
merde, pardonnez-moi, d'être grossière
et on montre un petit peu comment ça se
passe. Soit effectivement je sais pas,
je vois voilà, je suis assez inquiète en
fait sur l'avenir de ce pays.
Ça a été reçu euh difficilement parce
que vous les remettez en question, parce
que vous montrez des choses. Comment
vous avez fait pour infiltrer ce petit
milieu ?
En fait, ce qui est marrant, c'est que
ça a commencé euh j'ai j'ai je prends
toujours des notes moi à longueur de
temps en fait. Et en fait, j'ai je me
suis lancée dans la campagne municipale
à Paris avec plus ou moins de réussite
d'ailleurs. Mais et là, je rencontrais
plein de petits fonctionnaires, enfin
petits fonctionnaires, j'aime pas le
terme d'ailleurs, c'est une connerie. Je
rencontrais plein de fonctionnaires de
terrain, euh des policiers, des
infirmières,
des fonctionnaires de la territoriale,
des artisans, des commerçants, plein de
gens. Voilà, plein de gens. Et tous, ils
avaient des idées assez géniales sur
tout le fonctionnement français. Chacun
dans sa chacun dans son dans son monde
quoi. OK. Et en fait, il disait en
permanence écoute voilà j'ai des idées
super mais en fait j'ai 15 mecs
au-dessus de moi qui juste
m'engloutissent sous la paperasserie en
permanence et qui qui me demandent de
faire des choses qui n'ont aucun sens et
c'est absurde et je comprends pas
pourquoi on m'écoute pas.
Des exemples ?
Ben tu vois par exemple, j'avais
rencontré un mec qui est assez
extraordinaire qui veut développer le
frais de fluvial à Paris notamment.
C'est vrai que Paris est une ville
complètement embouteillée. On passe
notre vie, les écolos tous à dire "Ah
mais il faut qu'il y ait beaucoup moins
de voitures dans Paris". Mais on
s'occupe pas du tout de la question des
livraisons dans Paris. Or Paris il y a
la scène quoi. Donc pourquoi on ne se
sert pas de la scène ? Donc déjà moi
j'ai été rencontré tous les tous les
gens qui travaillent autour de la scène,
tous les fonctionnaires. C'était
horrible. Je rigole bêtement mais parce
qu'il y en a un qui m'avait dit "C'est
extraordinaire, c'est la première fois
qu'on voit une politique qui s'intéresse
à nous." Je me disais les pauvres, ils
sont pas sortis le cul des ronces parce
que
je suis quand même pas élu. Mais bon, en
tout cas, c'était passionnant et donc je
me suis dit c'est quand même inoui que
personne n'aille les voir alors qu'il
t'explique comment un tu peux doubler
quasiment la navigation que tu as sur la
la scène, que tu peux rendre tous les
les bateaux hyper propres pour très peu
d'argent, c'est pour 20 millions
d'euros, ce qui rien à côté du budget du
budget annuel de Paris. Donc tout ça est
à porté de main et on ne le fait pas.
Donc ça c'est quand même complètement
complètement absurde. Et je j'ai
rencontré notamment le patron de Fluidis
et donc lui il a il a fait une péniche
qui devait être mis à gaz électrique
pour faire effectivement les livraisons
pour pour IKEA pour pas la nommer. Etth
et en fait quand il a commencé à
travailler sur son prototype
il avait il voulait vraiment vraiment
faire mi gaz mi électrique. Et là en
fait quand il a essayé d'avoir des
subventions, il a dit non mais gaz gaz
on gaz ça n'existe pas. et mi gaz mi
électrique, ça n'existe pas. Donc le mec
dit mais en fait c'est une novation donc
ça n'existe pas encore bien sûr. Et euh
et là on lui dit non mais si ça n'existe
pas on vous subventionnera pas. Et donc
du coup il a fait mi diesel mi
électrique et si tu veux et là je me
suis c'est pas possible en fait on a des
gens géniaux qui ont des idées
fantastiques en permanence et on les
écoute jamais. Et après le déclic
ça a été le moment du Covid.
Ce moment, enfin, comme tout le monde
hein, je l'ai vécu de façon hyper
violente. C'est-à-dire, j'ai eu ce
sentiment, je sais pas si vous vous
l'avez partagé, mais de décadence en
fait. C'est-à-dire que ça faisait hyper
longtemps que on se disait "Ah,
l'Allemagne est en tête mais on décroche
pas, on est quand même on a on en a
encore sous le pied quoi." Et là, en
fait, on a eu ce sentiment
d'affaissement de notre pays.
C'est-à-dire que pour rien, on était
prêt quoi. On avait pas de masque et en
plus non seulement on avait pas de
masque mais on nous disait que ça
servait à rien pour cacher le fait qu'on
en avait pas. On avait pas de test alors
que ils étaient capables de mettre en
place des tests genre en un mois. Et
j'ai eu ce sentiment de
pas de respirateur
on avait pas de blouse. Voilà, c'était
c'était vraiment l'affissement du pays
et l'affessement du pays par la tête
parce qu'à côté de ça les fantassins sur
le terrain enfin les tu vois les
hospitaliers ils étaient là, ils étaient
là, ils travaillaient, ils étaient pas
protégés. Alors après, on pouvait les
applaudir, tu vois, parce que vraiment
c'est juste une honte, quoi. Et euh et
du coup là, je me suis dit en fait tous
ces fonctionnaires que j'ai rencontré,
toutes ces personnes que j'ai rencontré
pendant la campagne et tout ça, comment
ils gèrent là maintenant, on est en
plein cœur de la crise, comment ils
gèrent leur région, comment ils gèrent
leur métropole, comment ils gèrent,
comment ils sont. Et tous ces gens-là en
fait tous les jours, je les ai appelé 15
fois par jour, j'ai mais comment vous
faites et tout. Et en fait, je je
faisais autant mon enquête qu'une
presque leur psychanalyse à eux et la
mienne en même temps. Et j'avais euh le
président des services techniques d'une
grande région qui me disait "Écoute,
voilà, là tu vois c'est dingue, je suis
sous l'eau, je m'en sors pas, j'ai pas
d'aide, j'arrête pas d'envoyer des SMS à
Maton, on me répond pas." Ils me disent
qu'ils sont sous des rimes, donc les
réunions interministérielles qu'ils
enchaînent les rimes, ils me répondent
pas et cetera. Donc le mec était seul,
vraiment seul au feu, tu vois.
Et après, il m'appelle au bout de 3
semaines de confinement, il me dit
"Alors là, tu vois, c'est
extraordinaire. Je viens de recevoir
la la brochure magnifique en couleur de
comment confiner ma région 3 semaines
trop tard, hein." Et il dit, "On
pourrait se marrer, on pourrait trouver
ça presque drôle si tu veux."
Il y a des gens qui meurent.
Un, il y a des gens qui meurent. deux,
il l'avait pas confiné comme c'était mis
dans la brochure.
Donc il a été obligé à la marge de
rectifier pour pour ressembler à la
brochure. Et si tu veux là, il y a un
moment juste les mecs, mais venez sur le
terrain quoi. Venez sur le terrain,
soyez là, accompagnez-les plutôt
dédicter tous vos trucs depuis Paris, de
jamais être là quand on a besoin de
vous, mais par contre de de nous
enquiner en permanence, tu vois, après
quand c'est fait, quoi. C'est c'est
c'est un truc et c'était au fond, tu
vois aussi un cri de colère. Ça ça aucun
sens. J'avais le patron d'une grande
région que je ne citerai pas qui
m'expliquait comment il planquer les
masques. Il me dit "J'ai acheté des
masques, j'ai prévenu la préfet, j'ai
prévenu le ministère de la santé, je
leur ai dit que j'avais une filière."
Ils m'ont dit qu'ils en avaient rien à
[__] Tu m'entends ? Ils m'ont dit
qu'ils en avaient rien à [__] Et
après, il a flanqué ses masques parce
que il y a eu la guerre sur les tarmacs.
Tu te souviens ? C'est-à-dire que au
fond quand les quand les régions qui
avaient tout alerté en disant "Mais nous
on peut passer par la Chine, on a
l'habitude de passer par la Chine pour
certains trucs, on peut passer par
ailleurs et cetera." On leur a rayonné,
on les a pris pour des nazes. Sauf
qu'ils ont eu les masques avant l'État
et qu'après les préfets venaient sur le
Tarmac réquisitionner les masques. Donc
si tu veux, je je et tu te dis à un
moment, est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a un
moment toutes ces énergies qu'il y a sur
le terrain, tous ces gens qui bataillent
au quotidien comme ils peuvent hein, on
pourrait les écouter, tu vois ? Et
jamais, tu vois, jamais.
On a appelé le titre de notre émission
les census de la République, point
d'interrogation.
Ouais, il faut enlever le point
Pose la question nous.
C'est bien.
C'est une certitude pour toi ?
Ouais, je pense. Ouais, je pense que
c'est c'est une catastrophe. Et en plus,
si tu veux, je trouve qu'au fond, il se
cache même plus. Enfin, je Alors,
écoute, je sais pas comment vous avez
pris euh le rond de serviette que notre
ancien premier ministre
Édouard Philippe a pris chez Athos. Mais
enfin, donc il va être au conseil
d'administration, je sais pas, conseil
d'administration d'Athos, c'est quoi ?
20 50000 € par an, je pense. Euh,
ça fait pas beaucoup quand même.
C'est D'accord. Ça fait rien, hein.
Qu'est-ce que c'est hein ? quand on est
maire à pleinttemps du Havre he parce
que c'est déjà un tout petit job maire à
pleintemps du Havre ça ça ça ne te prend
pas de temps pour y aller 4 c fois 20
500000 on est d'accord
donc c'est-à-dire que au fond le
gouvernement a nommé comme commissaire
à Bruxelles Thierry Breton ancien patron
d'Athos
et et comme bon et remerciement de ces
bons et loyaux services, on on a son
rond de serviette en en sortant de la
politique tout en sortant pas tout en
restant maire du Havre
Et là, si tu veux, moi je pense qu'il y
a un moment ça rend fou ça en fait.
C'est-à-dire que non seulement ils sont
à la tête de la technructure, ils font
n'importe quoi avec l'État, mais
n'importe quoi. C'estàd que c'est une
décision idiote à la seconde. En plus,
ils se prennent pour des costillers mais
comme je dis dans le bouquin, tu vois,
avec la vision d'un lapin nain, et je
n'ai rien contre les lapins nains, je
pense qu'ils ont même peut-être plus de
vision que ces techno, mais en plus en
faisant manger entre guillemets, en
nourrissant toute toute la filière
privée. C'est-à-dire que tu vois quand
ça c'est même pas besoin d'infiltration.
Je parce qu'on a des fonctionnaires qui
font très bien leur travail en France.
Quand tu lis
il faut remonter des très bonnes
informations. D'ailleurs, on leur dit
merci.
Exactement.
On a une kirelle de fonctionnaires, des
petites mains besogneuses de l'État qui
nous tiennent au courant de ce qui se
passe.
Bien sûr.
Et on les remercie publiquement d'être
notre propre service de renseignement.
Mais ça m'étonne pas parce que moi j'ai
j'ai travaillé comme comme vous et j'ai
fait comme vous. Et là, tu vois, même
euh je sais pas si je dis vous ou tu
parce que du coup je vous dis, je vois
la moon tu et euh mais même les rapports
de la Cour des comptees, quand tu vois
les rapports de la Cour des comptes de
2018 qui te disent déjà c'est pas
possible en fait cette façon qu'on a eu
de faire traiter toutes les réformes de
l'hôpital par des trucs de consulting
privé. Les mecs viennent tous d'ancien
cabinet ministériel, d'accord ? Une fois
qu'ils sont passés par les ministères,
ils vont dans faire du consulting privé.
Ils nous vendent leurs conseils pour
démanteler l'hôpital. La Cour des
comptes elle-même dit "Ces conseils sont
nuls, ils sontreux et il démantelle
l'hôpital." Et tu vois là, j'en j'arrive
même plus à en parler. Le Covid est
passé par là, on a vu la catastrophe
qu'ils avaient réussi à faire à
l'hôpital. Et ben, en sortant de Covid,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On rappelle les
mêmes pour qu'ils nous refassent des
mêmes conseils privés aussi merdiques
que la première fois. Donc enfin quand
je dis la première fois que les 15
autres fois précédentes et et si tu veux
il y a un moment je cette impunité-là
juste je ne comprends pas en fait je ne
comprends pas comment comment
pensent-ils qu'en fait ils vont
continuer comme ça dans cet entre soi le
plus total sans aucun contrepouvoir à à
au fond euh être en train de de de de
voilà de de de profiter du système ? Je
suis désolée mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être un peu violent la façon dont
je m'exprime mais mais je suis en fait
je suis assez en colère quoi. Oui, je
suis assez en colère. Alors, ils vous
disent "Non, non, mais non, non, mais en
fait euh c'est pas vrai ce que vous
dites. Euh euh on n'arrête pas de
d'essayer de changer le système, mais
c'est faux. Ils veulent pas le changer
le système." Tu sais, j'ai regardé du
coup parce que leur choc de
simplification depuis 1990, ils nous en
parlent. [__] depuis 1990, ils nous
disent qu'ils font du choc de
simplification.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
La France, c'est quand même un gros
bateau. Il y a de l'inertie. Il faut
prendre son temps. Parle.
Mais c'est eux. C'est eux l'inertie,
c'est pas nous. Tu vois, je veux dire
là, regarde, pendant le Covid, on l'a vu
la France, elle était à 2000 à l'heure.
Elle trouvait des solutions tout le
temps sur le terrain. C'est eux qui sont
dans l'inertie. Mais pourquoi ? Parce
que ça ça ça leur convient en fait, ce
système leur convient
ou pas ? C'est c'est peut-être qu'ils
ont pas été formés pour réagir en
situation de crise, ils ont été formés
pour faire perdurer le rondron
quotidien. Ça c'est vrai. Alors ça c'est
vrai mais c'est presque, si je puis me
permettre l'explication optimiste. Moi
j'ai l'impression que là la formation
elle est très très bien faite pour
ouvrir son parapluie hein parce que ça
par contre ils l'ont fait de façon
magistrale. C'est-à-dire qu'on voyait
bien que pendant la crise les mecs
étaient juste en train de préparer les
procès à venir en se disant attention là
pas de papier litigieux rien qui puisse
nous nous mettre dedans. Attention et là
regarde ce qui se passe avec les fac.
Non, on ça quand même là on est reparti
ça fait 15 jours, 3 semaines qu'on nous
dit le Covid machin et cetera. Les fac
ils ont édicté des trucs en disant voilà
les fac il faudra mettre de l'espace
entre chaque étudiant, faudra c, faudra
ça. Tu as vu les amphies bondés de de
Mom là collés comme ça là ? Je veux dire
donc pourquoi ils édictent ces règles ?
Pris le Récemment.
Bah c'est pareil.
Donc en fait on édicte les règles
pourquoi ? Pour être couvert on pourra
pas dire qu'on vous l'avait pas dit. Et
après, on refile la p la patate chaude à
qui ? Au mec sur le terrain qui lui doit
se débrouiller. Parce que qu'est-ce que
tu veux qu'il fassent les patrons des
fac ? Tu vois, je veux dire, c'est il y
a un moment, ils font ce qu'ils peuvent.
Ils ont des locaux lépreux, ils ont
plein de gamins à gérer, ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent avec l'absence de moyens
à laquelle ils doivent faire face. Tu
vois,
question d'internet. Comment sommes-nous
arrivés au point où un politique bosse
en même temps chez un particulier ?
comme c'est comment c'est légalement
possible
avec le conseil d'administration ? C'est
devenu le ces nouvelles Anapurna de de
de la de la caste. Avant quand tu étais
quand tu étais un grand techno, ton rêve
c'était d'être en ministère, tu vois,
c'était leur leur truc. Maintenant, ils
ont trouvé un nouveau truc, c'est leur
rêve, c'est de rentrer dans le dans le
capitalisme d'affaires. Bon, c'est et
oui, c'est légal. Oui, ils ont le droit
de le faire. Euh et non, je trouve pas
ça normal. Et en plus, je suis désolée,
mais je trouve que ça nourrit cette idée
que au fond, il a été euh c'est c'est
pour c'est pour bon service rendu.
Enfin, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Donc
le patron d'Au se retrouve à Bruxelles
comme notre ancien premier ministre
était bon.
Ben peut-être parce qu'il était bon,
mais enfin bon, en tout cas, il s'y
retrouve. Euh notre ancien premier
ministre se retrouve au conseil
d'administration d'Athos. Enfin, je sais
pas, on vous a appelé vous pour aller au
conseil d'administration d'Atos ?
Euh non.
Ben moi non plus. Nous nous on nous
attend on attend qu'on nous appelle pour
prendre la direction de la DGSE.
Ah mais c'est bien ça. Non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est
on a toujours rien eu hein.
Non mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
a quand même un sujet là-dessus. Après,
après on peut aller tous pleurer quand
ils sont en train de licencier 900 mecs
de Bridget Stone parce que la boîte
ferme. Mais enfin, c'est facile quoi.
Donc on pleure hein mais on accompagne
ce capitalisme d'affaires. On y
participe en étant dans les conseils
d'administration puis on garde un pied
en politique puis peut-être on y
retournera un petit peu plus mais on est
quand même maire du Havre. Je a un
moment ce mélange des gens. C'est plus
possible vraiment c'est plus possible.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ? Est-ce que
est-ce que tu as tu as d'autres exemples
de de pantouflage, rétro pantouflage, de
de trucs qui tont un petit peu choqué ?
Mais mais moi les trucs, les
pantouflages, j'en a un million. Mo
Sarkozy, c'est devenu le roi des
conseils d'administration, hein. Tu
vois, je veux dire mais mais regarde
même le grand truc de la France, c'est
dire non OK, l'État dysfonctionne mais
ne vous inquiétez pas, on va créer une
autorité administrative indépendante. OK
? Donc ça c'est le grand truc, c'est que
généralement quand tu sais pas quoi
faire du chemil bic, quand c'est bien
puant, tu crées une administration, une
une autorité administrative
indépendante. OK ? Sauf que quand tu
regardes comment elles sont composées
ces ces autorités, qu'est-ce ou
financer, qui est-ce que tu retrouves
dedans ? les mêmes. Donc les mecs, ils
viennent de l'ENAT, Cours des comptes,
inspection des finances, conseil d'État,
ils sont tous parisiens, ils sont tous
passés par des ministères, ils vont tous
y repasser dans cette autorité
administrative indépendante.
Rappelle-toi, ça avait fait le moment où
on a su qu'elles existaient, c'est quand
il y a eu Chantal Joanau, tu te souviens
qui était occupé du grand débat, qui
était censé s'occuper de
l'administration indépendante qui
s'occupait du grand débat national, mais
elle avait dit qu'elle ferait pas le
grand débat. 15000 balles par mois pour
dire que tu le fais pas. Elle a
peut-être pas eu tort de pas le faire
parce que
15000 € par mois. Oui. Donc si tu veux,
je veux dire donc alors maintenant ça
c'est censé contrôler, disrupter le
système.
Disrupter ça veut dire
ben c'est au fond c'est s
secouer le système. Ouais, tu as raison.
C'est un néologisme qui a pas de sens.
Mais donc voilà, donc à partir du moment
où tu trouves dedans des gens qui
viennent du système qui aspirent à y
retourner, tu d'où à quel moment on
pense qu'il va se passer quelque chose
pour changer le système depuis ces ces
ces autorités administratives
indépendantes ? Sauf qu'en attendant, ça
coûte de l'argent.
Ça monopolise des gens brillants qui
pourraient être monopolisés à faire
autre chose. Ça finalement ça permet de
squeezer le parlement puisque ils sont
responsables devant qui ces gens-là ?
Devant personne. Donc si vous voulez au
fond tout est fait quelque part pour que
cet état profond échappe au contrôle
démocratique.
Pourquoi tu appelles ça état profond ?
Je sais pas. C'est effectivement une une
expression qui est utilisée souvent et
qui est pas bonne.
Qui est pas bonne en plus. Tu as raison.
Enfin en tout cas pour que ces
métastases bureaucratiques puissent
continuer à perdurer hein, ce serait
plus juste tranquillement et je veux
dire à s'en créer une par jour. Et quand
je dis une, je suis je suis un petit peu
psymiste. Je pense qu'on doit être
plutôt à 15 métastases par jour minimum.
Et c'est un truc de fou. Tu vois, ce
matin, j'étais euh je je fais aussi de
la de la de la télé de la radio et
j'étais aux grandes gueules de RMC. OK.
On recevait Améline Monchalin qui était
très très remonté, donc la ministre de
la fonction publique chargée elle aussi
elle encore de la simplification
administrative. D'accord. Donc c'est la
20e qui va s'en occuper.
Ça on va avec. Voilà. Donc elle est elle
est pas désagréable hein. Elle parle
comme un fichier Excel. Elle a
l'empathie du fichier Excel. Et euh et
donc elle était en train de nous
expliquer que vraiment là elle allait
faire ce qu'elle fallait vraiment on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir. La
simplification c'était demain. D'accord.
Et donc elle nous parle de plan de
relance. Et qu'est-ce qu'elle nous dit
sur le plan de relance ?
Des petits préfets.
Des sous-préfets à la relance. Donc si
tu veux, c'est-à-dire que fort du
constat que quand même pendant le Covid
la seule le seul échelon qui est
fonctionné c'est l'échelon local. On est
d'accord. Donc fort de ce constat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? et ben on
l'humilie l'échelon local et on lui crée
des sous-préfets, hein, pour bien le
faire marcher au fouet si tu veux et
pour bien l'humilier. Et du coup, je dis
mais enfin du coup enfin pardonnez-moi
madame le ministre mais grosso modo en
France on a à la louche 200 préfets 500
sous-préfets. Déjà une centaine une
petite centaine de de préfets hors cadre
6000 balles par mois quand même à rien
[__] hein. Pardon, excuse-moi d'être
un petit peu grossière. Enfin, c'est ça
les sous-pressés hors cadre. Euh
on les remercie pour services rendit
peut-être. Ben sûrement, certainement.
Enfin, moi on m'a jamais proposé d'être
préfet cadre. C'est comme le Mond
Servieste au conseil d'administration me
l'a jamais proposé non plus. Et
en fait tous ces gens-là et ben c'est
pas comme si c'était déjà enfin je sais
pas c'est enfin je c'était pas suffisant
déjà comme technructure. Qu'est-ce qu'on
a besoin de nous rajouter encore ? Une
couche quoi une couche de sous-préfet.
Alors donc du coup c'estes sous-préfets,
ils vont sortir. Donc je me suis procuré
la circulaire de monsieur Jean Castex,
notre nouveau premier ministre qui comme
il parle avec un accent chantant, on
nous fait croire que que le mec est
vraiment il est il est rural, tu vois.
En fait, juste c'est le techno pur
souche comme rarement on en a fait. Et
tu regardes la circulaire, elle fait
trois pages, elle fait hyper flipper. Et
donc il est là en train de te dire les
mecs seront na + 2, + 4, + 6. Donc na +
6 déjà ça fait peur hein. Je sais pas ce
que ça peut être na + 6 mais c'est un
truc déjà rien que d'en entendre parler,
tu te dis he tu as du mal à respirer. Et
si tu veux ils sortiront l'école, ils ne
ils ne connaîtront pas le terrain et on
va les faire doublonner avec des
sous-préfets qui seront déjà installés
sur place. Et ces gens-là donc qui ne
connaisseront qui ne connaîtront pas le
terrain seront là pour gérer le terrain
et comme elle me le disait débloquer les
problème qui pourraient qui qui pourrai
survenir. Juste juste mais juste ils
vont créer des problèmes tous les jours.
Tu vois
c'est une bonne idée.
Bah une idée de une idée de merde de
plus. Mais c'est mais comment c'est
possible ?
Essayons essayons de voir la chose
différemment.
On se retrouve avec un gouvernement
volontaire, empathique, dévoué à son
peuple et qui se retrouve avec une
technructure dont il a hérité et elle
est pas très performante. Donc il est
obligé de rajouter une petite couchette.
Non mais
c'est ça.
Je je me fais l'avocat du diable
optimiste. C'est ça.
Ben écoute, tu vois quand tu reprends le
par exemple, tu vois, moi je j'étais
j'étais hyper énervée en écoutant euh
les politiques passées au moment de du
Covid quand j'entendais Xavier Bertand
nous dire et j'avais créé Prus qui était
une espèce de petite structure
administrative qui commandait des
masques et cetera et à ce moment-là on
avait j'arrive plus à me souvenir
c'était 1 milliard 4 ou 1 milliard 7 de
masque et cetera. Donc je commencé à
regarder à creuser sur la la comment
c'était constitué. Et et Prus, c'est
constitué exactement comme tu le dis,
c'est-à-dire fort du fait que au fond
l'administration était pas capable
d'être réactive pour commander des
masques en période de crise, pour
finalement s'émanciper des appels
d'offre parce que là on est resté avec
les appels d'offre habituels, des
marchés publics pour acheter des masques
en période de crise, hein. Enfin, faut
quand même faut quand même que que les
gens qui qui vous écoutent aient
conscience de ça. On était on n' pas
changé notre mode de fonctionnement hein
avec les mêmes trucs, les mêmes
lourdeurs administratives. Bon,
nous sommes en guerre.
C'est ça. Donc on avait beau le dire, tu
vois, on disait vous êtes en guerre mais
en même temps, tu vois, on partait avec
une course de vitesse avec des plombs au
pied et les mains attachées dans le dos
et les yeux bandés si tu veux. Et vas-y,
gagne ta course de vitesse. Bref, donc
Prus, c'était ça. C'était l'idée au fond
de faire un court-t-ircuit. Sauf que
quand Bertrand c'est est parti,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Bah en fait
comme Prus avait été faite contre Ber
parce que au fond la première chose dont
il faudrait se débarrasser c'est c'est
les 100000 mecs de Ber he c'est
peut-être hyper bien fait pour faire de
la norme personne même le conseil même
la cour des comptes nous dit que aucun
pays européen ne nous l'envie hein c'est
beaucoupat dans l'état
c'est l'état dans l'état
et Prusse
Berti n'en voulait pas considérer que
c'était trop cher que c'était c que
c'était ça donc dès que Bertrand s'est
s'est barré enfin dès qu'il a plus été
ministre
Ils ont squeezé et Prus qui est passé de
genre 280 millions d'euros par an de de
frais de fonctionnement enfin de de
budget pardon à genre 23 ou 24 millions
et il trouvait que c'était trop cher.
C'était trop cher. Mais chaque jour de
confinement a coûté combien de de
milliards à la France si tu veux. C'est
ça le problème. Donc oui, c'est malin de
créer une petite une petite un petit
cour circuit, un petit bypass. C'est
malin. Si ce n'est que dans ces cas-là,
comment tu fais pour le péréniser ? Tu
n'y arrives pas. Tu vois, il y a un
moment ça ne fonctionne pas. il meurt en
même temps que le politique qu'il a mis
en place meurt ou il est rattrapé,
englobé dans la technure. Donc en fait
soit et je te dis pas que ce soit simple
hein, je te dis pas que j'ai la
solution, je l'ai pas, mais soit on
s'attaque vraiment à ce mode de
fonctionnement, c'est-à-dire qu'au fond,
tu vois, on on on va à la hache dans
cette dans cette technure.
Il faut pas dire ça parce que on va à la
hache.
Non, on va pas à la hache physiquement
mais bien sûr, certainement pas. Mais en
tout cas euh je veux dire on en finit
avec les 100000 mecs de Bercy qui sont
juste bons à créer de la norme chaque
jour et depuis Paris et qui mettent
toute leur intelligence qui est immense
à nous enquiquiner en permanence et on
fait enfin un état girondin en France
parce que je veux dire comme en
Allemagne enfin l'Allemagne elle
fonctionne comme ça elle fonctionne très
bien je veux dire qui nous envie quand
tu vois par exemple les services de
santé en Allemagne en gros on met autant
d'argent eux que nous dans les services
de santé la seule différ différence,
c'est qu'en Allemagne, c'est géré au
niveau de la région en fait. Donc chaque
région est responsable de ses hôpitaux,
de ses effectifs. Il y a beaucoup moins
d'administration que chez nous. Si si on
avait l'équivalent de administratif,
enfin, tu vois, de l'Allemagne, on
aurait 100000 soignants de plus sur le
terrain. Donc, si tu veux, voilà. Et
sauf que tu vois le patron de région
quand il fait un mauvais choix, il est
responsable, il tombe. Chez nous, on a
quoi ? On a les ARS, les agences
régionales de santé dont on a vu que
pendant ce Covid que elle se parlait
alors elles se parlait pas entre elles,
elles avaient même pas le même système
informatique pour communiquer entre
elles. Je sais pas si tu imagines, tu
vois tous ces trucs là. Elle ne parlait
pas au préfet qu' donc elle considérait
comme un sous-être à qui elle avait pas
à s'adresser. Elle ne parlait pas au
maire. Et donc là, tu te dis non mais du
coup on fait comment ? C'est qu'on est
en période de crise, tu as le ministère
de la santé, tu as les agences
régionales de la santé. ses agences,
elles se parlent pas entre elles, elle
ne parlent pas au préfet, elle ne parle
pas au maire. Je veux dire, il y a aucun
pays au monde qui nous envie tous ces
échelons intermédiaires. C'est c'est pas
possible. Enfin, comment c'est possible
qu'à chaque fois que la France dit "Je
vais décentraliser, elle crée une espèce
de métaste." C'est pas possible.
Pourquoi on a créé ces agences
régionales de santé ? Enfin, pourquoi on
n'est pas capable de faire de faire
confiance au terrain, au patron de
région ? On dit qu'on veut faire des
grandes régions. Mais mais qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire ? Regarde, je veux dire
comment tu veux faire ? Elles sont
sous-dotées en moyens, elles ont pas de
moyens les régions. Je veux dire, la
région Île-de-France a a même pas moitié
moins de moyens que Paris. Qu'est-ce que
tu veux qu'elle fasse la région
Île-de-France ? Qu'est-ce que tu veux
qu'elle fasse ces régions ?
Alors, question d'internet de Mathieu.
Comment pourrait-on mettre des
contrepouvoirs pour lutter ? Ben moi je
pense déjà qu'il faut changer
entièrement le mode de recrutement de
ces élites. Moi je pense qu'il faut moi
je suis un truc tu moi je je suis petite
fille d'émigré donc je crois beaucoup à
la promotion républicaine sauf qu'elle
marche plus en France tu vois ça marche
plus. Donc moi je pense déjà qu'il faut
faire émerger d'autres gens tu vois des
gens qui viennent de banlieu des gens
qui viennent de la diagonale du vide
mais ces gens-là ils pourront jamais
passer les nain tu vois enfin ils
pourront de temps en temps passer les
nainas pas
de temps en temps ça passe. Enfin
c'est-à-dire que maintenant on est hyper
content. Ils appellent ça le je sais pas
comment le côte à diversité. Donc ils en
font passer un si tu veux et comme ça ça
se voit pas que le reste est uniforme.
Mais enfin on voit bien qu'il y a une
reproduction des élites en France et ça
date pas d'hier. C'était déjà bourdieux
qu'il le disait mais enfin là on est
arrivé à un niveau de reproduction qui
n'est pas possible. Donc déjà il faut
changer ce mode de de de reproduction.
Après pour qu'il y ait des
contrepouvoirs qui existent il faudrait
déjà que le Parlement puisse avoir du
pouvoir. Or quand on commence à regarder
ça c'est très intéressant. C'est un peu
compliqué mais c'est très intéressant
quand tu regardes le processus
législatif en France, c'est un truc de
fou. C'est-à-dire que tu tu te rends
compte que quand tu as un projet de loi,
partout ailleurs euh en Europe, partout
hein, tu tu dessines en fait, tu tu fais
se rencontrer toutes les forces vives du
pays, tu regardes et tu dis voilà, on a
eu telle idée, est-ce que vous pensez ?
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que ça
pourrait marcher, que ça pourrait pas
marcher ? Quelles seraient les
conséquences ? On discute, on voit entre
entre eux et on voit ce qu'on peut
mettre en place. Pas en France. En
France, c'est trois jeunes techno sur un
coin de table qui disent tiens
si on faisait ce projet de loi, il il
voit même pas avec les autres ministères
si par hasard ça ça va ça va empiété ou
pas. Non, continue. Ils font une étude
d'impact. L'étude d'impact, tu penses
que c'est qui qui l'a fait ? Que là
encore
Oui, c'est ça. Là encore, les forces
vives, non, pas du tout. Là, c'est
encore trois technos sur un coin de
table. L'étude d'impact par exemple de
la loi sur le travail et le commerie,
c'est trois lignes. OK ? Donc trois
lignes, tu imagines bien comme tout a
été anticipé hein. Trois lignes. OK ?
Après ça passe en conseil des ministres.
Non attends là il demande un avis du
Conseil d'État. L'avis du Conseil d'État
n'est jamais rendu public. Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi il est pas rendu public ? Cet
avis du Conseil d'État ? C'est quand
même une chance en France d'avoir le
Conseil d'État toutes ces têtes bien
faites, hein. Et ben, il est jamais
rendu public parce que tous ces mecs-là
aspirent à rentrer au cabinet
ministériel. Et donc si tu veux, ils
vont sans doute dire à leurs copains bah
écoute là tu vois c'est une vraie
connerie ça sans donner tout autre et
cetera mais faut pas que ça sache hein
faut pas saouter entre soi. D'accord ?
Donc là tu vois déjà on est dans un truc
où tu as consulté personne tu fais une
étude d'impact médiocre tu demandes des
conseils à des gens mais on les rendra
pas public et après tu arrives en
conseil de ministre et là tu te rends
compte que cette loi merveilleuse
finalement elle empiète sur toutes les
les autres ministères et que c'est quand
même le boxon. Bon, très bien, ça
freine, c'est dur. Très bien. Là, on a
encore parlé à personne, hein. D'accord.
On est encore à 20 techno. D'accord. Ça
arrive devant le parlement. Là, le
parlement est prévenu quoi ? 15 jours, 3
semaines avant. Il connaît pas la loi.
Il a tous les tout tout à tout à
ingurgiter. Il comprend quasiment que
dalle. Euh, on lui file des amendements
fisclés généralement par les lobbyes,
hein, ou par le gouvernement.
Clé en main, clé en main. clé en main,
hein. Donc il comprend rien, il vote là
où on lui dit de voter. Il y a quand
même l'opposition qui essaie de faire
son job. Du coup, inflation
d'amendement, du coup, tu vois la
navette entre les deux entre les deux
chambres et à la fin, tu as en gros une
loi qui fait 60 % de plus en taille que
ce qu'elle faisait au départ.
On ne lagarde pas, c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
fait pas d'étude d'impact pour voir ce
que ça modifie, quelles sont les
conséquences sur la société civile, sur
les secteurs économiques que ça devrait
impacter. Ça a pris 30 mois. 30 mois
et un quinquena c'est 60 mois hein. Et
généralement quand elle ruelle jusqu'à
nous hein, elle est obsolète. Et sauf
que pour la défaire, tu vois, dans les
pays anglo-saxons, par exemple, tu as ce
qu'on appelle une une clause de
revoyure, c'est-à-dire au bout de 2 ans,
soit ça marche et tu la pérénise, soit
ça marche pas et la loi elle saute
d'elle-même.
Et ben pas en France. Donc il faut
repartir dans le même processus
législatif ma qui va reprendre 30 mois.
Et là si tu veux, du coup les gens ils
se disent "Mais c'est quand même
incroyable, je vais voter pour Macron,
j'ai l'impression d'être sous Hollande".
Mais c'est normal, vous êtes sous
Hollande. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
tu es sous Sarco quand tu es sous
Hollande, je veux dire ça ça n'avance
pas ça n'avance pas et rien que ça c'est
un contrepouvoir hyper important les
champs parlementaires. Mais il faut leur
rendre leur pouvoir.
As voté quoi aux dernières élections ?
Ah bon ? Moi je vais dire franchement
j'ai voté Macron au second tour.
Qu'est-ce que tu voulais que je fasse ?
Bah j'aurais pu ne pas aller voter,
c'est vrai. Euh mais je ne me voyais pas
ne pas aller voter. Je l'en jeu. J'y
suis pas allée la la fleur au fusil. Euh
je n'ai jamais fait partie des
macronistes éblouis parce que parce que
j'étais pas macroniste. Par contre,
j'espérais, j'avais très peur que ce
mec-là soit au main des lobby. Pardon,
d'utiliser ce terme qui paraît un peu
complotiste, mais j'en avais peur.
C'est-à-dire que je ce jeune type
brillant qui arrivait à récolter autant
de pognons si facilement, j'ai toujours
trouvé ça très angoissant. Ce mec qui ne
s'était jamais, comment dire, frotté à
aucune élection locale. J'avais trouvé
ça très angoissant.
Mais j'espérais au moins un truc, c'est
qu'effectivement il avait été élu, j'ai
jamais cru mais quand même petit truc
quand même que il avait quand même été
élu sur ce truc de dire
les forces vives de la nation, c'est la
startup nation quoi hein. Startup
nation, on allait voir ce qu'on allait
voir. Les technos, c'était fini hein. On
allait plus en voir un seul et ça allait
mais tous les jours ça allait être un
truc mais on allait avoir une innovation
technologique par jour et ça allait
aller à 3000 à l'heure. En fait, on est
on est bah enfin on est au même point
voir pire qu'avant. La technure elle est
enfin rappelle-toi. Enfin, moi je sais
pas si ça vous a choqué ou pas, mais moi
ça m'a choqué cette grande enquête qu'il
avait eu dans le monde cet été sur Marc
Guillaume. Marc Guillaume, c'était
l'ancien secrétaire général du
gouvernement. Et tu avais ce mec dont tu
apprenais qu'il avait tenu des propos
misogynes qu'il était infect et cetera
et cetera. Il avait été nommé sous
Hollande,
il était resté sous Macron et qu'en fait
il t'expliquait que comment lui tout
seul il décidait les projets de loi, qui
martyrisait les ministres en les
empêchant de faire les réformes qu'ils
avaient envie de faire et qu'il était
tout-puissant et que tout le monde
tremblait devant lui. Et là tu te dis
mais on est sous Macron, on est sous
Startup Nation là on a le on a le même
on a les mêmes que quand on était sous
Hollande on a la même technure
surpuissante.
Et le mec là on a vu que c'était quand
même c'était pas grandchose ce type là.
Du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand un
mec là tu vois tu pointes du doigt, il
est misogyne, il est atroce, il a
martyrisé tout le monde pendant x
années. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Ben sa
punition c'est d'être nommé préfet
d'Île-de-france.
Ça a été prouvé qu'il a martyrisé tout
le monde là ? Bah écoute là, tu vois, je
après du coup moi j'ai quand même pas
mal passé de coup de fil et on dit bah
ouais mais nous on savait on savait je
mais une fois que le mec tu vois écloué
au pilorie tout le monde te dit on
savait on savait c'était atroce et
machin mais quand ils sont en place et
toutpuissant personne ne dit rien et toi
et moi on a même pas conscience qu'il y
a un mec son métier c'est c'est au fond
tout seul et toutpuissant de penser
qu'il va dicctter toutes les les lois de
la République et qu'il est tellement
plus intelligent que nous tous réunis
qu'il a besoin de personne.
Mais comment on a pu créer ces monstres,
mais vraiment ces monstres que sont les
arques qui pensent à ce point-là qu'ils
sont tellement plus intelligents que
nous qu'ils ont pas besoin de nous ?
C'est pathologique.
Ah ouais, moi je pense que c'est Ouais,
je pense que c'est pathologique. Je
pense qu'on a un vrai sujet avec ça. Et
je pense que si tu veux quand tu fais
sortir de l'école des gamins de 20 ans
en leur disant que ce sont des dieux sur
terre et qu'après tu les mets dans tous
ces systèmes où finalement ils sont
jamais confrontés à la vraie vie en
fait. Enfin mais pardon mais tu vois
quand quand ce directeur des services
techniques de de cette grande région qui
me dit j'étais en panique enfin j'étais
en panique pas dit comme ça mais enfin
on sentait c'était très angoissant
d'avoir à gérer le confinement de sa
région et qu'il avait en en au téléphone
des gamins qui disaient on est en rime
des réunions interministérielles. On
passe d'une rime à l'autre, mais on vous
demande pas d'être en rime. On vous
demande de venir aider, on vous demande
d'être en bas, on vous demande d'être
sur le terrain, tu vois. Mais sauf que
les mecs, ils passent leur vie à faire
du jus de crâne et comme ils sont
intelligents, tu veux, ils ont une idée
à la con par seconde à faire du jus de
crâne et cette idée, ils essayent de
l'appliquer verticalement, tu vois et et
ça n'a pas de sens en fait.
En parlant de de d'idée à la con,
question d'internet, peut-elle expliquer
son bashing spécial Micolo ?
Alors ça c'est pas un
Pourquoi selon elle après Macron il n'y
a plus personne pour diriger la France ?
Ah j'ai pas dit j'ai pas dit après
Macron il y a plus personne pour diriger
la France. Bon j'espère bien que si. Euh
si non, j'ai jamais dit ça. Mais par
contre le bâolin, je raconte l'histoire.
Euh il se trouve que donc je fais cette
émission de radio et télé là qui est
grandes gueules de RMC et que euh
venait d'arriver cette idée de du maire
de Bordeaux de qui dit euh
au milieu d'une cinquantaine de
propositions
au milieu d'autres propositions mais qui
dit effectivement qu'il est contre
l'arbre mort de la place machin truc et
comme juste avant on avait eu le droit à
d'autres ma colo qui avaient dit que le
Tour de France était pas possible c'est
vrai que j'ai j'ai j'étais pas très
contente en fait. Je vais vous dire
pourquoi je suis pas très contente. Moi,
je suis écolo quand même depuis un bon
paquet d'années, hein. Je
Pourquoi écolo ? Ça veut dire que je
pense que au fond euh si tu veux changer
ce pays, si tu veux changer euh euh
entre guillemets la face du monde,
pardonne-moi d'être un peu
grandiloquante, ça passera par des
réformes fortes effectivement sur
l'agriculture, sur les énergies
renombables, euh sur le la modification
des transports. On a vraiment
neuf fluvial, le machin le truc. On a
vraiment des chantiers incroyables,
incroyables. D'abord pour faire société,
pour vivre mieux et pour propulser la
France dans tu vois dans un avenir
intelligent, intéressant. au fond, il
faudrait capable aujourd'hui de d'avoir
la vision que qu'on qu'on pas
aujourd'hui sur le nucléaire, mais qu'on
eu les gens qui ont pensé le nucléaire
en se disant ça, on va mettre beaucoup
d'argent et voilà ce qu'on va créer dans
20 30 40 ans. Alors, j'espère qu'on
créera pas de de pâte à caisse comme le
nucléaire mais en tout cas il faudrait
prendre des risques. Nucléire,
je suis contre. Je suis contre parce que
une technologie dont tu ne sais pas
gérer les déchets, je pense que c'est un
vrai problème. Mais euh peut-être que tu
tu me prouveras le contraire, mais enfin
pour le moment, je suis très inquiète de
ça. Et je pense en plus qu'on a un vrai
sujet sur sur la Je pense qu'on se met
en danger. C'est-à-dire que pour avoir
publié un livre d'un Erwan Benzé la
catastrophe du nucléaire si tu veux
cette idée de ne pas même avoir protégé
contre les attentats potentiels nos
centrales qui sont des cibles
potentielles, je suis très inquiète de
ça. Le fait effectivement qu'on soit
contre le nucléaire, donc ça fait 40 ans
qu'elles sont en place et elles sont en
train de se fendre de partout. on on ne
met pas l'argent nécessaire pour
finalement les réhabiliter. Donc là
effectivement, on a un problème, c'est
stop ou encore mais si c'est en mais si
on continue à les faire marcher, il va
falloir quand même mettre du pognon
dedans pour pas que ça nous pète à la
gueule parce que ça c'est on a quand
même un vrai sujet là-dessus. Bon bref,
parenthèse euh terminée euh sur ce sur
ces
Tu savais que pendant le le Covid, il y
avait des gens qui se confinaient dans
les centrales pour pouvoir assurer au
cas où euh
C'est dingue ça mais ça m'étonne pas.
Quamp lit de camp ration de survie
c'est dingue
c'est intéressant ils étaient prêt he
et
donc si tu veux du coup je trouve que
ces mères écols ont suscité une
une espérance incroyable et c'est vrai
que je pour moi on attendait deux en
fait qu'en arrivant ils disent voilà tu
vois par exemple un très très beau un
très très beau sujet c'est celle de
l'incinération des déchets. Ça a l'air
comme ça à Noin. est pas du tout. En
France, on brûle nos poubelles. Or, les
poubelles, si tu veux un/ers de nos
poubelles, ça pourrait être au fond du
compost, ça pourrait être des engrais,
ça pourrait, tu vois, je veux dire, on
on on brûle de l'eau et on brûle des
choses qui pourraient nous servir et qui
sont une ressource naturelle. Ça n'a
aucun sens. On on trie hyper mal nos
poubelles et on crame tout ça. C'est
polluant, c'est onéreux et c'est
éminemment subventionné par nous.
Moi, j'aurais aimé qu'on mette sur la
table. Quitte à avoir des sujets
clivants, ces sujets là et c'est quand
tu arrives que tu les mets sur la table
et tu dis voilà sous mon sous ma
mandature, on va modifier. Je m'engage à
ce qu'on modifie l'incinération, je
m'engage à ce qu'on fasse des maréchages
autour des villes, je m'engage à ce que
les captages d'eau, patati patata. Vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ? J'attendais
d'eux d'être à la hauteur des espérances
qu'ils avaient suscité. Et pour le
moment, je trouve qu'il qu'ils n'y sont
pas. Donc je ne vais pas les juger, ils
viennent de commencer. Mais si vous
voulez en fait quand arrive, c'est tout
de suite qu'il faut poser les jalons été
élu avec beaucoup de voix, avec beaucoup
de personnes qui ont ce qui ce qui me
paraissait hallucinant c'est euh je
trouve qu'on est arrivé au bout du bout
du système, c'est le taux d'abstention
auquel on a assisté en fait pour ces
élections. Si tu veux, je moi je vais
dire un truc. Donc je m'étais présenté
au municipal, je n'ai pas voulu faire le
second tour à cause de ça. J'ai dit
c'est pas possible. D'abord, on a fait
le premier tour avant le Covid. Moi, je
m'étais battu comme une folle. Comme une
folle. Je te montrerai, si tu veux le
SMS que j'avais envoyé à Annie d'Alg qui
m'a jamais répondu en la suppliant
littéralement de s'opposer à la tenue du
premier tour parce que je trouvais que
c'était criminel de faire ce premier
tour. Personne, tout le monde, tous les
politiques se sont battu pour qu'il ait
ce premier tour. Tous. L'archer
l'archer a fait un lobby dégueulasse.
Dégueulasse hein.
Pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Parce que il est allé.
Macron pour le coup, il les aurait bien
comme il savait bien que ça lui ça lui
réussirait pas terrible hein. Peut-être
que c'est pour ça mais enfin bon en tout
cas il voulait les annuler ses élections
et l'archer est allé le voir il a
commencé à crier au déni démocratique et
tous les partis ont emboité le pas hein.
Donc on a fait voter les gens. Moi c'est
toutes mes équipes se sont covidées à ce
moment-là. D'accord. Et
covidé
covidé covidé. Elles se sont pas
confinées, elles se sont covidées.
C'est-à-dire qu'on était là, on faisait
campagne, on covidait les gens, euh on a
faisait des réunions de campagne. Euh
c'était vraiment mais c'est on a fait
n'importe quoi. N'importe quoi.
C'est que là, tu es en train de dire que
les politiques étaient vecteurs de
Covid.
Mais bien sûr. Enfin, tous les gens
qu'on rencontré, enfin c'était n'importe
quoi ce qu'on faisait. Enfin, c ça
n'avait pas de sens.
Il a eu le Covid,
je crois pas.
Mais euh donc moi j'ai vraiment j'étais
contre ce premier tour et après donc on
a fait ce premier tour qui n'avait aucun
sens d'un point de vue démocratique, qui
n'avait aucun sens plus grave ou au
moins aussi grave d'un point de vue
sanitaire qui a fait prendre des risques
aux gens. Et après on a fait la tartufie
du second tour. Oh le premier tour est
gellé, on va faire le second tour. Tout
va très bien madame Martise. Enfin
pardon entre le premier tour et le
second tour le monde s'était écroulé.
Le monde s'était écroulé. Qu'est-ce que
ça voulait dire ce cette élection d'un
point de vue démocratique ? continuer la
cantine. Ah
[__] la cantine, tu meen parles pas,
tu enfin je crois pas si bien dire.
Comment c'est possible que ça ça nit
germé dans la tête de personne qui avait
des milliers de gamins en France qui qui
vivaient et qui mangeaient bien le midi
à cause de la cantine, grâce à la
cantine pardon. Et comment on s'est pas
posé la question de comment ils allaient
se nourrir pendant le Covid ? Comment si
tu veux avec l'explosion qu'on a vu des
des des fils d'attente de gens qui
n'avaient plus à manger à leur fin, on
s'est dit que c'était une bonne idée de
continuer comme si de rien n'était les
élections, le machin, le truc. Comment
on n pas été capable à ce moment-là, à
ce moment-là de dire "Écoutez les
élections en fait, stop, on s'en fout
là, on se met tous autour d'une table,
on réfléchit, on réfléchit même à ce que
c'était que les métropoles." Enfin,
rappelle-toi ce qui a été Paris pendant
le confinement. Moi, j'étais à Paris
pendant le confinement parce que je n'ai
pas voulu partir de Paris pour plusieurs
raisons. La première, c'est que je ne
savais pas si j'étais que si j'avais le
Covid ou pas vu la campagne que j'avais
faite. Et il était hors de question pour
moi d'aller dans ma famille en Bretagne
parce que j'avais trop peur d'emmener
dans une région qui n'était pas
contaminée le Covid. Donc, je ne je ne
n'aurais pas pu me regarder dans une
glace si j'avais quitté Paris comme un
rat euh en apportant le Covid ailleurs.
Et deuxièmement, je trouvais important
d'y être et de voir comment ça ça
fonctionnait. Paris a fonctionné comment
et grâce à qui ?
Les livreurs
les livreurs, les petites mains, les
sans papiers.
Paris a fonctionné grâce à tous ces
gens-là, à tous ces gens qui après on
s'étonne du taux de mortalité en scène
Saint-Nie, qui est-ce qui venait
s'occuper de tous ces métiers là ? Les
gens qui vivaient en scène Saint-Denis,
à ce moment-là, on les a fait venir tous
les jours sans masque en prenant le RER,
sans aucune protection et on les a
renvoyé tous les soirs chez eux. Pas une
fois, pas une fois cette gentry de
gauche, hein, parce que pardonne-moi
mais là moi je suis vraiment en colère
hein, cette gentry de gauche qui est à
Paris ne s'est dit "Les hôtels sont
villes, sont vides, on les loge, on leur
propose euh de les loger pour pas au
moins qu'ils se mettent en danger avec
leurs allers-retours." Au moins ça, il
rend pas compte. Mais il faut pas leur
donner le goût du luxe. Après, il
risqueraiit de demander d'autres choses.
Je me fais l'avoquer du diable. Mais on
s'est compris. Ben moi, j'ai trouvé ça,
je trouvais enfin ça c'est des gens de
gauche, ça c'est ça c'est la gauche
parisienne. Ben moi, je suis désolée
mais je comprends pas et je n'ai pas
compris non plus que comme acte fort en
sortir de Covid, la seule chose que que
nous a dit Hidalgo, c'est il faudra
surtout pas que ils reprennent leur
bagnoles en gros quoi. Donc si tu veux
donc c'est ça les villes, ça va être des
bastillons de CSP plus hein, qui vivent
retranchés à l'intérieur des murailles
de notre métropole. qui sont alimentés
par entre guillemets des petites mains
qu'on paye mal, qu'on rejette en banlieu
et qu'on ne veut surtout pas voir si
possible pas avec leur voiture qui pu
donc en RR hein de toute façon c'est
bien déjà enfin tu vois je veux dire il
y a un moment tu vois on s'est pas posé
ces questions là quoi. On s'est pas posé
ces questions là on a fait le deuxième
tour ah tout va très bien c'est super et
moi j'ai j'ai pas trouvé ça à la hauteur
en fait.
Bon revenons à notre sapin de Noël.
Ouais. Bon ben le sapin à Noël si tu
veux. Moi cette idée de dire un arbre
mort, un arbre mort, j'ai trouvé ça
complètement idiot en fait. Voilà donc
j'ai dit une idée à la con par jour.
Peut-être que j'aurais pas dû le dire de
façon aussi forte mais si tu veux ça
m'est sorti comme ça me sort parce que
j'ai j'ai un petit caractère et euh
est-ce que tu peux essayer de reformuler
ça avec bienveillance ?
Bah si je devais le formuler avec
bienveillance, je le formulerai
exactement comme je te l'ai dit tout à
l'heure. C'est-à-dire que là ils
viennent d'arriver, il y a des chantiers
colossaux qui qui sont devantux. Euh, on
les attend là-dessus. On les attend
devant effectivement une ceinture
maréchère autour des grandes villes. On
les attend devant des transports
propres. On les attend euh euh avec la
rénovation thermique. On les attend avec
euh la fin de les incinérations des
déchets. On les attend sur toutes ces
choses-là en fait qui sont des choses
vraiment enfin je veux dire je veux dire
ils vont pas nous faire le la leur leur
mandature avec les pistes cyclables
hein. Enfin on a bien compris qu'ils
étaient pour tu vois. Je veux dire, je
suis hyper contente, j'adore le vélo,
tout va bien. D'aille, j'ai pas une
passion pour le vélo. Mais bon, quoi
qu'il en soit, en tout cas, c'est pas
c'est pas un marqueur. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Les pistes cyclab, on est
très content qu'ils en fassent, mais
enfin ça peut pas être ça l'écologie. Ça
peut pas être que ça, tu vois. Et après
ça peut pas être de ne penser que la
métropole intramurose. Moi ce qui
m'angoisse le plus, tu vois, et ça ce
qui était très intéressant dans cette
campagne que j'ai faite, on devrait tous
faire une campagne municipale dans notre
vie. C'est de voir à quel point ces
métropoles sont des ogres. En fait, ce
sont des ogres de toute la banlieue qui
les entourent. Mais des ogres, c'estd
tous ceux qui font vivre Paris par
exemple, tous ils vivent en banlieu. Les
profs, les institutes, les aides
soignants, les policiers, les mecs qui
s'occupent des déchets,
les livreurs,
tous,
on ne les loge pas dans Paris. OK. On ne
les loge pas dans Paris. Euh il y a un
problème quoi. Je veux dire c'est c'est
donc après tout ce qui nous déplaît dans
Paris, les incinérateurs de déchets,
les incinérateurs d'humain en fait hein,
les cimetières, les cimenteries, c'est
aussi
un très bel il y a un très bel
incinérateur bah pour d'ici limou là.
Oui, tout ça c'est en banlieu donc au
fond, si tu veux, il y a moi ce qui
m'angoisse, c'est au fond, on est en
train de s'installer dans une espèce de
sécession des CSP+ métropolitains
par rapport à la France, de la diagonale
du vide et des banlieux. Et je je pense
pas que ça puisse continuer comme ça en
fait. Dites les mecs, on va pas rester
dans notre truc là, dans notre
forteresse assiégée en en pensant que ça
va continuer comme ça à Vitam. C'est pas
possible en fait
avec les marauots et les mans.
C'est ça
en périphérie.
Bah c'est ça.
Euh questionnet. Croit-elle à un green
New Deal en la croissance verte pour
l'interrogation ? Sinon cela pose-t-il
problème lors des soirées en tête à tête
avec Yannique Jad ? Alors, j'avais pas
vu la fin de la question, je voulais pas
parler de
Non, mais c'est pas grave, tu peux en
parler de toute façon. Je je veux dire
je
Ça t'a fait quel effet quand c'est le
point qui non l'ops qui a sorti un
papier. était compagne d'eux. Mais tu
sais de toute façon depuis que je suis
avec lui, c'est comme si tous mes
neurones de pour pour avaient disparu et
que je n'étais que le porte-parole
d'eux. Alors, il se trouve que
tu n'avais pas ton intégrité propre.
Et j'ai pas mon intégrité propre et je
ne suis que
Tu es tu es une bonne bobonne.
C'est ça.
Tu es une bonne bobonne.
C'est ça. Et quand je gueule, comme j'ai
gueulé pour les pour les ma écolo, on me
dit "Ah quand même, vous êtes la
compagnie d'eux, vous ne devriez pas
dire ce que vous pensez." Donc les mecs,
il faut choisir votre camp, hein. Soit
je suis une collabo, une porte-parole,
soit je ferme ma gueule et je reste à la
maison. Mais je veux dire, il y a un
moment je peux pas, voyez, on peut pas
me reprocher les deux. Donc de fait, je
dis ce que je pense et je fais ce que
j'ai envie de faire. Et euh et euh oui,
moi je enfin moi je je vais vous dire un
truc, je suis pas du tout je je suis pas
décroissante, je suis pas collapsologue.
Moi, je pense qu'il faut prendre le
meilleur de tout. Et c'est-à-dire que si
la technologie nous permet d'arriver à
une agriculture plus vertueuse euh et
quand vous discutez avec les mecs qui
font euh qui qui travaillent sur
vraiment l'agriculture bio aujourd'hui,
la permaculture, l'agroécologie, c'est
des gens hyper pointus, hyper
techniques, d'accord ? Ça ça ne les
empêche pas d'avoir le bon sens paysan
machin et cetera, mais c'est vraiment
des gens très très pointus. Je pense
qu'il faut pas se priver de la
technologie. Par contre, la technologie
a tout craint sans se poser les
questions des répercussions, je suis
contre, mais je suis pas décroissante,
je suis pas collapsologue. Je pense pas
qu'on va s'en sortir en vivant dans une
newt et en faisant plus société. Ça
vraiment c'est pas mon truc. Je vais pas
vous dire le contraire.
Tu sais avec quoi on a annoncé ton ton
interview, tu sais, on aime bien
discuter avec du mois communiquer avec
notre langage vernaculaire.
On a annoncé ton passage avec un clip de
The Cardigan.
Ouais.
C'est my favorite game. Je te je sais
pas si tu te rappelles du clip, c'est
une nana qui monte dans une décapotable
qui met un une pierre sur l'accélérateur
et qui va pleine balle sur la file de
gauche.
C'est ça. C'est ça Isabelle Saporta.
C'est c'est une nana qui qui a son
intégrité qu'on a rien à je peux parler
vulgairement. Ouais.
qu'on a rien à branler et que
et que vas-y, elle respecte son point de
vue, elle a ses valeurs et c'est pas la
bob la bobonne 2.
Ah non, c'est pas la bonne 2. Si tu
veux, je me suis pas pris tous les
procès que je me suis pris. Je me suis
pas, tu vois, je enfin moi je veux dire,
j'avais rien à gagner par exemple à à me
prendre en frontal le lobby du bordela.
Je peux dire que quand j'ai eu quand
quand j'ai eu toutes les lettres
d'huissier de machin à la maison et que
et que j'ai vu ça, je me suis mis
comment ? Mais pourquoi je me suis gagné
? Non, j'ai toujours gagné tous mes
procès. J'ai été mise en examen, j'ai
toujours gagné tous mes procès. Donc euh
des perquisitions chez toi ?
Non, mais par contre effectivement, j'ai
reçu ces lettres d'avocats qui disaient
qu'il me demandait des sommes mais
délirantes, colossales,
mais des centaines de milliers d'euros,
tu vois, et qui me disait en plus c'est
des toutes petites sommes qu'on vous
demande parce que pour le pour le
bordel, c'était des sommes dérisoires et
pour moi c'était juste des années
d'emprunt si je devais enfin c'était pas
c'était pas envisageable. Et donc je me
suis pas tapé tout ça tout ça parce que
je pensais que c'était important euh
voilà d'être de dévoiler certaines
choses, d'être au côté des des gens qui
avaient été spoilers et cetera pour que
maintenant je sois assigné à résidence
et que je puisse plus dire ce que je
suis parce que je suis avec quelqu'un.
Tu vois ça a pas de sens quoi.
La fin de la question c'était quoi ?
Cela pose-t-il des problèmes lors des
soirées en tête à tête avec Yannick Jadu
?
Ouais, on s'engueule, ça arrive. Ouais,
il y a des choses sur lesquelles on
n'est pas d'accord. Il y en a beaucoup
même. Mais mais du coup
vous avez pas décidé de de mettre un une
distance professionnelle quand vous
rentrez à la maison ?
Bah moi, je sais pas toi, mais moi je
suis euh
alors moi je suis vraiment animée par ce
que je ce que je fais quoi. Donc si tu
veux, j'arrive pas à rentrer chez moi et
à me dire euh "Ah bah ouais mais au fond
la techno la technructure est en place,
ils ont encore eu trois idées à la con
aujourd'hui mais on s'en fout parce que
là tu vois on est à la maison et donc ça
nous intéresse plus." Moi c'est vraiment
un truc ça me ça me ronge en fait. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? ça me
bronche, ça m'habite quoi. Donc je
j'arrive pas effectivement à arrêter.
J'arrive pas à arrêter. Et c'est vrai
que tu vois sur ce truc sur les mers
écolo, j'étais vraiment en colère et
j'étais vraiment en colère. Je m'étais
déjà engueulé avec Yannick là-dessus
pour tout dire parce que je lui dis mais
c'est pas possible, ils ont une chance
historique de faire des choses
incroyables. Pourquoi ils se perdent
dans des controverses qui n'ont aucun
intérêt ? Tu vois, tu crois aux écologi,
je crois à l'écologie. Je crois à
l'écologie. Je pense que c'est la
matrice qui peut nous propulser, tu
vois, dans
nous faire gagner de l'argent, nous
faire sauvegarder de l'argent.
Moi, je pense que
si tu veux, moi je suis hyper inquiète
de la fracturation du pays. D'accord. Je
pense qu'aujourd'hui euh comme euh
l'État providence, comme ne remplit plus
son rôle, comme la méritocratie n'existe
plus, je veux dire comme le léviatant
est boîteux, puisque c'est ça, le léviat
est boîteux, finalement chacun se
réfugie dans un communautarisme,
d'accord ? Et chacun est dans sa dans
son petit groupe. Or, on fait plus
société. Je pense que l'écologie
parce que elle nous touche dans ce qu'on
a de plus viscéral et de plus humain,
dans l'angoisse qu'on a de manger des
choses polluées, de respirer un air
pollué et cetera, elle pourra nous
permettre d'avoir la trame pour refaire
société. Donc je pense que c'est
vraiment important. Je pense que c'est
vraiment la nouvelle matrice, tu vois.
Je veux dire pourqu dit la nouvelle
religion. Moi j'ai horreur des
religions. Donc sûrement pas la nouvelle
religion. Par contre, la nouvelle
matrice qui nous permet de faire sens,
oui, mais du coup, il faut être à la
hauteur les mecs. Il faut vraiment être
à la hauteur. Parce que si on n'est pas
à la hauteur, mais mais qu'est-ce qui va
se passer ? Quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ? Il va se passer que la seule
réponse, ce sera quoi ? Ce sera au fond,
ce sera ce sera un Trump à la française.
Je sais pas qui ce sera mais ce sera ça.
Moi, j'ai pas du tout envie de ça, en
fait.
Logiquement parlant, c'est quoi tes tes
tes scénaris à court et moyen terme ?
en terme d'effondrement de la
biodiversité. Ah
voilà ça
affaiblissement
affaiblissement des sols
moi je suis catastrophée mais enfin ça
si tu veux je suis catastrophée et je
suis catastrophée que
le covid n'osait pas fait prendre
conscience de tout ça
parenthèse il y a Jean-Michel qui nous
dit "Elle raconte vraiment n'importe
quoi sur les appels d'offre
c'est sur les appels d'offres de quoi ?
À mon avis, ça doit être sur les
masques.
Ah non, mais ça je peux Alors là, je
suis prêt à le mettre en contact avec
les personnes en charge là-dessus. On
est resté hyper longtemps, peut-être que
à toute fin ça s'est arrangé hein, sur
les mêmes systèmes d'appel d'offre, les
mêmes. On n' pas été capable de squeezer
euh ces systèmes là au niveau étatique,
hein. Je dis pas au niveau régional.
Bref, donc euh si tu veux, moi je j'ai
cette chance d'être éditrice. Éditrice,
c'est au fond comme ce que tu fais,
c'est créer sa communauté autour de soi.
Et j'ai j'ai édité, j'ai cette chance
d'éditer un homme qui s'appelle Serge
Moran et qui est écologue et qui
travaille au CNRS depuis des années et
qui depuis des années nous prédit les
pestes à venir. OK. et il y a eu le
Covid et ce livre qu'il a qui qui qu'il
a publié qui s'appelle qui qui est sur
ses nouvelles pestes euh si tu veux, il
explique le système dans lequel on est.
C'est-à-dire que au fond à chaque fois
c'est la même chose. À chaque fois, on
se retrouve avec une chauve-souris qui
se retrouve qui qui se retrouve
au-dessus par exemple d'un élevage de
cochon industriel en Malaisie, dans un
pays musulman, si tu meux. Pourquoi ?
Parce que la Chine a décidé qu'elle
allait exporter ses ses élevages por
industriels. Pourquoi elle est Pourquoi
elle est pas dans la forêt tropicale ou
pourquoi elle est pas dans la forêt la
la
chauve-souris ? Parce que on a
déforesté. Euh elle elle se retrouve sur
ses cochons, elle jit sur le cochon,
elle le contamine. On est dans un
élevage industriel, ça devient une bombe
bactériologique, on contamine les
éleveurs, on contamine les gens qui
travaillent dans les avatirs et bim,
à chaque fois c'est la même c'est la
même logique et on le sait et on le sait
depuis des décennies. Et au lieu de
répondre à ça en disant "Bah écoutez, en
fait l'élevage industriel ça n'est pas
possible, la déforestation ça n'est pas
possible, il faut mettre un haa à tout
ça, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On fait des
espèces de trucs biosécuritaires,
c'est-à-dire qu'on essaie de dire "Ah
non mais l'élevage, il sera
biosécuritaire, on va ériger des
murailles, vous verrez, il y aura pas un
un il y aura pas un miasme qui passera."
Mais les miasmes y passent hein. On a
bien vu avec les labos de Wan ce qui
s'est passé. On est dans un truc où on
n'est pas capable d'assurer le
biosécuritaire. Alors arrêtons de faire
ça. Arrêtons de [__] en l'air la
biodiversité puisque on se met en danger
là maintenant. On le sait qu'on se met
en danger mortel.
Donc non, je suis catastrophée. Je suis
je suis catastrophée parce que rien ne
change parce que la déforestation
continue au même rythme parce que
l'effondrement de la biodiversité enfin
c'est c'est enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est hallucinant. Et on répond à quoi
ça ? Ben Macron, il a remis en place les
néonicotinoïdes. C'est que la seule
petite avancée il a remis que sur les
betteraves.
Ouais enfin que sur les betteraves.
Alors je vais reprendre je vais
reprendre parce que Jadou il s'est fait
remettre à sa place par la nana de la
FNSEA. Elle a dit euh la betterave elle
fait pas de fleurs ou elle fait des
fleurs que tous les 2 ans donc les les
abeilles elles vont pas être touchées.
Alors moi ce que j'aimerais c'est parce
que elle est très intelligente Christian
Lambert ou
peut-être que Jado était pas équipé pour
lui tenir la drager. Ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'elle lise, mais je suis sûre
qu'elle les connaît déjà, euh les
travaux d'un chercheur au CNRS qui
s'appelle Vincent Bretagnol et qui
t'explique qu'aujourd'hui en fait ces
néonicotinoïdes ce sont souvent des
semences enrobées, que en fait ces
pesticides, ils restent dans le sol he à
90 %. que en fait on s'est rendu compte
en utilisant euh ces que que qu'en
regardant finalement avec des cultures
qui ont été faites des années plus tard
que les plantes euh plantées des années
plus tard, elles arrivaient à refaire
sortir des néonicotinoïdes qui étaient
restés dans le sol que dans l'eau.
Quelle proportion ?
Pardon ?
Dans quelle proportion ?
Dans les proportions ? Alors tu vois là,
j'ai pas révisé mes néonicotinoïdes
avant avant de venir chez toi, mais
demande à tes internautes de regarder
Bretagnol si tu veux. C'était très
intéressant parce que je l'avais mis
dans un des précédents ouvrages. J'ai
oublié les proportions. Parfois si tu
veux sur les plantes qui étaient qui
étaient plantées après hein, il y avait
plus de néonicotinoïde en teneur
que ce qu'il y avait de façon initiale.
Donc on ne sait pas en fait comment ça
fonctionne. Ça veut dire que on sait que
ça reste dans le sol. On ne sait pas à
quel point les plantes finalement si tu
veux s'en s'en ressaisissent. On ne sait
pas pourquoi ça ça c'est à ce point-là
dans la flotte. On nen sait rien. On
sait qu'on ne sait pas. Tu vois, il y
avait un très bon article de Stéphane
Fouard dans le monde l'autre jour qui
racontait euh qu'il y avait eu des doses
vraiment infinitésimales de
néonicotidoïd euh si tu veux sur les
risières et que ça avait vraiment
anéanti entièrement des des élevages de
poissons qui avaient depuis des des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années et
alors que c'était des doses
épiphénoménales, vraiment presque rien.
Donc si tu veux, ce qu'on sait avec les
néonicotinoïdes, c'est que c'est une
saloperie, qu'on y connaît rien et que
ça désingue la biodiversité et que on ne
sait pas pourquoi par moment certaines
plantes le le ressortent en quelque
sorte. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Et
tu sais comment il avait fait Bretagnol
? Il avait mis des puces RFID sur les
abeilles en fait. Donc le mec a été
c'est quand même pas rien. On a quand
même des chercheurs, ils sont
extraordinaires en France. Donc il
c'était tu vois vraiment c'est le truc
est est est est imparable imparable.
Donc ça elle le sait très bien Christian
Lambert. Donc si tu veux moyennement
il le savait pas.
Oui bon peut-être je lui avais dit mais
enfin tu vois il avait peut-être ça lui
était peut-être sorti de la tête j'en
sais rien. Puis après je tu vois je
tu trouves crédible Jado ?
Bah oui
mais bon tu vois je sais pas
je trouve bon.
Ouais je trouve bon ouais
et je trouve bon. Je trouve crédible.
C'est vrai que je crois en lui, tu vois.
Maintenant maintenant je suis pas là
pour faire son Tu vois, je suis pas là
pour faire la la
voilà ni ni la claque, ni les pom girl,
ni machin. C'est à lui d'être
suffisamment bon et crédible pour pas
qu' que moi qu'il trouve bon. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? Quoi ? Il y a un
moment c'est à lui de de de montrer que
non seulement il y a pas que lui mais
qu'il y a un projet.
Il est assez franc pour toi.
C'est compliqué d'être politique hein,
ça je vais te dire c'est pas simple. Moi
je sais pas s'il est franc ou pas franc.
Ce que je vois c'est que tous autant
qu'ils sont lui y compris. C'est vrai,
ils ne disent pas exactement ce qu'ils
pensent au moment où ils le disent. Moi
je le vois bien tous, ils sont tous
pareils parce qu'ils ont la trouille.
Ils ont la trouille. Ceux de gauche se
disent "Ah mais si je dis ça, ça va être
un truc de droite. Si je clique pas
là-dessus, si je tweete pas là-dessus,
si je rebondis pas là-dessus, que vont
penser les autres ?" Mais on s'en fout
en fait. Je veux dire, les Français s'en
foutent de tout ça. Je pense que les
Français au fond, les Français sont se
se contreficent des des parties des
postures aujourd'hui.
Il faut nous rendre la France.
Ouais. Moi je pense comment on fait pour
nous rendre la France ?
Ben je pense que déjà si tu veux, il
faut qu'on ait conscience qu'il faut
qu'on la reprenne. Ça c'est très
important. C'est-à-dire que je pense
qu'il faut qu'on se tu vois qu'on se
qu'on se on s'en saisisse de cette
France, qu'on se dise pas "Ben voilà, la
technure est en place.
C'est le petit monde, c'est l'entre soi,
il y a rien à faire. Il faut déjà qu'on
on retrouve confiance, qu'on ait
conscience de tout ça et qu'on retrouve
confiance en la France, en notre
courage, en notre possibilité de faire
avancer les choses. Et au moins ça, je
suis persuadée, tu vois. Je suis
persuadée que ça c'est à porortter de
main en fait parce que regarde pendant
le Covid, les mecs dans les régions, les
mecs dans les villes, les mecs dans les
villages, quand ils ont décidé de passer
outre tout, les appels d'offre, les
machins, les trucs, les bidules et
qu'ils ont mis les mains dans la merde
du soir au matin, ils ont réussi à
gravir la napurna 15 fois par jour. Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Donc c'est à
porter de main. Si tu veux, ce qui était
quand même assez fantastique pendant le
Covid, c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte
que tout était à porté de main. C'est
pour ça que si tu veux, je suis aussi en
colère contre Améline Monchalin quand
elle te dit "Bah oui, on a bien compris,
on va vous remettre des sous-préfets."
C'est pas possible, tu vois. C'est pas
possible en fait. Si on avait bien
compris, on arrêterait avec ces
conneries.
Question d'internet. Capitalisme et
écologie sont-ils compatibles ? Alors
moi ça me gêne toujours ces questions là
parce que en fait si tu veux la question
que je me pose c'est est-ce que
l'agriculteur bio, tu vois, qui fait ses
paniers, qui est en vente directe et
cetera, il est capitaliste ou il est pas
capitaliste ? Enfin, tu vois, on est
quand même dans une économie de marché
aussi là. OK. Comment on fait ? Tu vois,
c'est c'est ça ça si on est pour moi je
suis contre le capitalisme. Mais c'est
que là vous vous faites un vrai show
tous les deux derrière.
Ici, on porte son masque au-udessus du
nez.
D'accord. Moi, si c'est pour parler du
capitalisme financier complètement
délirant dans lequel on est,
effectivement où on remercie un ancien
premier ministre en lui offrant une
place dans un conseil d'administration,
ça c'est pas possible. Si tu me parles
du capitalisme à la Bridgestone où tu as
un mec qui envoie euh une vidéo une
vidéo pour dire aux 900 mecs que c'est
fini une vidéo
alors que les mecs ils ont des maisons à
payer des crédits à payer des gamins à
l'école que peut-être que maman et papa
travaillent dans la même boîte et ainsi
de suite. C'est ça
c'est atroce. Là j'en je j'ai j'ai j'ai
eu la chance de discuter avec un de ses
salariés. Il avait passé 38 ans dans la
boîte. Son père avait fait pareil. Son
fils y était aussi. Et là, tu te dis
"Mais c'est des vies entières, c'est des
vies entières qui s'effondrent."
Quand quand on entendait la l'émotion du
maire en fait aussi, c'est que tu te
rends compte que c'est c'est toute la
sociabilité entre guillemets, c'est
l'économie, la sociabilité du coin qui
s'effondre. Et on a mis en place quoi
pour aider ces gens ? Rien. Par contre,
on a mis en place le CICE, hein, pour
aider toutes ces boîtes. Le CICE, on a
contrôlé le CICE un peu.
Ouais, tu parles. Je veux dire, c'est
c'est ça qui est pas possible en fait,
c'est qu'on passe notre vie à filer du
du pognon, de l'argent public à toutes
ces boîtes, hein, pour qu'à la fin,
ouais, elle nous fasse ta raison, elle
nous fasse d'un bras d'honneur en fait
et qu'elle nous disent "Mais ça y est,
mais sauf que c'est pas possible."
Enfin, tu vois, ça peut pas être ça le
capitalisme. Ça peut pas être de dire on
profite de vos infrastructures, on
profite de votre système hospitalier, de
votre système de santé, de votre système
hospitalier, on profite de votre
formation, on profite du système de
chômage hein, puisque une fois que on
aura jeté les gens, ce sera pour nous
aussi. Et on ne vous doit rien. Enfin,
c'est pas possible. On peut pas
continuer comme ça. Mais ça, tu vois, ça
ça pourra pas se régler qu'avec la
France, hein. Faut qu'on revoit l'Europe
et ça c'est un vrai truc quoi. Mais on a
un vrai sujet avec cette Europe.
Question sur l'Europe. Donc vas-y.
Mais non, mais moi je je moi je moi je
suis profond crois l'Europe
Oui, moi je suis profondément proe
européenne. Je crois à l'Europe parce
que je pense que c'est si tu veux je
pense qu'au fond si on veut s'en sortir
demain, il y a deux échelons qui vont
tenir, les régions et l'Europe.
D'accord.
S'en sortir contre quoi ?
Ben s'en sortir dans cette espèce de
monde qui n'a plus aucun sens. dans
cette espèce de monde, tu vois. Je comme
je suis éditrice, je le répète pardon,
j'ai la chance d'éditer aussi François
Gemmen qui est un chercheur incroyable
qui va me faire un livre qui s'appelle
On a tous un ami noir sur toutes les
questions en fait pour tendre le coup à
tous les poncifs racistes puisqu'en fait
on on ne vit l'immigration qu'avec les
les clés de l'extrême droite. Est-ce que
l'Europe est à la hauteur de sa dignité
démocratique en laissant la question
migratoire en la en la donnant à Erdogan
hein ? en en considérant que c'est
normal qu'on soit une citadelle àég euh
en ne protégeant pas non plus euh ces
salariés puisque finalement c'est la
guerre de tous contre tous. Euh on n'est
pas capable de créer une souveraineté
médicamenteuse. Enfin, pendant le Covid,
on s'est rendu compte que on déjà pas
foutu d'avoir une souveraineté
numérique. Alors
alors, on n' pas de souveraineté
numérique, on n' pas de souveraineté
médicamenteuse. 80 % des molécules
viennent de Chine. Euh 97 % des
antibiotiques américains. Moi, je trouve
ça quand même assez délirant quand tu
imagines que Trump fait semblant de
faire la guerre avec la Chine. [__]
les mecs qui coupent l'antibiotique, ils
sont tous morts aux États-Unis. C'est un
truc hallucinant hein. Nous on fait
pareil hein. On n'est pas capable
d'avoir une souveraineté alimentaire et
on n'est pas capable d'avoir une
protection de nos salariés. Donc si tu
veux soit l'Europe au fond est capable
de de de créer ça, de créer en fait
cette espèce de d'énormes état
providence à 500 millions de personnes,
soit mais soit ça c'est c'est enfin ça
n'a plus aucun sens. Soit c'est juste
effectivement une technostructure, une
technure pardon productrice de normes à
la con hein euh qui ne sert à rien et
euh et pour le moment c'est ce qu'elle
est l'Europe. Mais moi, j'arrive pas à
me résoudre à ça. Enfin, ça peut pas
être ça l'Europe, quoi. Enfin, c'est
c'est c'est extraordinaire l'Europe.
C'est c'est un projet incroyable.
Pourquoi on en a fait ça ? Pourquoi on
en a fait cette espèce de truc là ? Je
comprends pas.
Si demain, Si demain, d'un coup de
baguette de magique
je te transforme, on te transforme en
notre présidente de la République,
quelle serait ta première mesure ?
J'ai envie de te dire, je foutrais en
l'airbery et les 100000 mecs qui sont
dedans. Mais en vrai,
avoir un contrôle fiscal,
carabiner, hein.
Mais je pense que c'est vrai en fait
quoi pour le contrôle fiscal. Non, c'est
possible. Mais ça c'est mais c'est
surtout que si tu veux, je je pense
effectivement que c'est ça qu'il faut
faire. C'est-à-dire qu'on a 100000 mecs
qui sont là dans un truc complètement
centralisé, qui ne pensent qu'à faire du
cost killing, des normes, serrer les
boulons,
qui ont tout centralisé, qui qui ne
s'intéressent pas du tout au territoire.
Je pense qu'on a un vrai problème avec
ça. Je pense que je fous en l'air les
aussi une bonne fois pour tout puisque
là on a donné à unarque le soin de
supprimer les oh c'est bizarre c'est
toujours pas fait.
Comment tu dis ? Comment tu dis ? Ah
oh, c'est bizarre, c'est pas fait. Et
donc ça c'est pas on peut pas continuer
comme ça, c'est voilà. Après, je je je
pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on réfléchisse
à la question de l'industrialisation de
la France. C'est-à-dire queon a eu quand
même aujour on a eu des technos et NARC
donc plutôt littéraires qui ont pensé
qu'on avait pas besoin de d'usine en
France, que l'industrie c'était sale,
c'était vulgaire et queon ne tiendrait
que avec des des postes de CSP plus hors
sol et que ça allait très bien se
passer. Bon ben écoute, non, en fait ça
très bien la com.
Ben oui, ils font la com. Enfin, c'est
pas possible, tu vois. Je veux dire,
c'est
comment on fait comment on fait pour euh
euh dégager les sculpteurs d'air chaud
et et les brasseurs de de fumée ? Bah
ouais,
comment on fait ? Parce que là, j'avais
une question, je l'ai pas passé encore
mais la question je la je la reprendrai
plus tard mais de tête ça disait aux
prochaines élections on fait quoi ? On
vote ou on se fâche ?
Mais c'est ça le problème.
Est-ce que tu sens cette cette rage
commençait à à gronder des campagnes ?
Ben écoute, tu sais euh moi les les gens
qui ont lu mon livre m'ont dit euh
l'avant l'avant-propos, l'introduction
est d'une extrême violence et en fait tu
les interpelles et mais parce que je la
ressens cette colère parce que je la
ressens moi-même. Je veux dire et puis
en plus j'ai envie de leur dire mais à
quel moment vous vous nous voyez en
colère ? Il y a eu les gilets jaunes
hein, il y a eu la grève pour contre la
réforme des retraites tu vois. Je veux
dire il y a eu tous ces toute cette
colère tu vois. Je veux dire, il y a un
moment, regardez-nous,
regardez-nous, écoutez-nous. Quand quand
euh après les gilets jaunes, Macron dit
"On va faire le grand débat national,
le truc qu'on terminé à la cave là les
Non, parce qu'il y avait les cahiers
aussi de comme doléances
et euh
si tu veux, moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
plutôt une bonne idée. Je simuler les
mecs, ils vont enfin nous écouter.
Youhou ! C'est super ! C'était partout
sur le territoire. C'était les mers,
c'était machins, c'était truc super.
Oui, tu as raison. C'était du violent.
Mais enfin, en tout cas, l'idée était
pas mauvaise. Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
accouché de ça ? Ils ont dit "Ah mais on
vous a bien bien écouté, on va vous
faire la réforme des retraites.
Mainant, on va bien vous
Mais c'est ça hein, on va faire la
réforme des retraites. Et qui est-ce
qu'il prennent pour faire la réforme des
retraites ? Un mec dont on nous dit que
pendant 18 mois, il a pas arrêté de nous
parler aux uns et aux autres. Enfin,
c'est quand même marrant. Je sais pas à
qui il a parlé hein, parce que je veux
dire, personne n'était content quand sa
réforme est arrivé.
euh sur pied et qui était conflicté
jusqu'à la jusqu'à l'os quoi. Et comment
c'est possible ça quoi ? Comment c'est
possible qu'on continue à faire des
bêtises pareil ? Je comprends pas en
fait.
Question d'internet, pourquoi ne pas
prendre en compte des mecs comme Jean
Covici ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Je je sais pas. Je
moi je c'est pourquoi je le prendrai
enfin je pourquoi je comprends pas bien
la question en fait. C'est-à-dire ça
veut dire quoi ? Je le prendrai pas en
compte.
Question internet.
Ben, je sais pas trop quoi répondre.
Autre question. Question de paysan
pratiquant l'agroécologie de points.
Êtes-vous prête à accepter de travailler
la terre et de gagner 400 € par mois ?
Mais mais ça c'est inacceptable. Je suis
entièrement d'accord. Moi, si j'ai écrit
foutez-nous la paix, si j'écris le livre
noir de l'agriculture, si j'ai écrit
Vino Business, c'est aussi pour ça.
C'est hallucinant. Comment c'est
possible ? Mais ça, pardon mais je veux
dire
qui est-ce qui a foutu les paysans dans
cette dans cette ornière ? Je veux dire,
c'est quand même l'Europe
ben non, c'est le syndicat majoritaire
hein parce que c'est la FNSE parce que
qui est-ce qui qu qui est-ce qui la
dirige l'Europe avec les 10 subventions
que que sur la PAC chaque année ? C'est
la FNSA avec son truc européen qui
s'appelle la COPA KOJKA. Qui est-ce qui
fait du lobbying pour que ce soit
toujours les mêmes qui obtiennent le
pognon, c'est-à-dire l'agriculture la
plus destructrice d'emploi, la plus
utilisatrice de pesticid et qui ne paye
jamais les dommages collatéraux ni en
terme d'antibiorésistance,
ni en terme de de dépollution des cours
d'eau. Je veux dire, qui est-ce qui qui
fait ça ? C'est pas l'Europe toute
seule, c'est le syndicat majoritaire.
Qui est-ce qui est monté au créneau là
pour réclamer les néonicotinoïdes ?
Voilà. Et comment c'est pas possible
aussi que Macron dise bon bah écoutez
bah la nana de la FNSEA avait dit voilà
si nous on va on arrête en gros ça va ça
sur l' l'industrie du sucre ça va être
compliqué c'est les Allemands et les
Belges qui vont récupérer le marché
mais alors
parce que eux vont pas arrêter
alors pardonne
ça c'était son
pardonne-moi ce truc soyons clair
là-dessus c'est évident que la
reconstruction écologique elle se fera
pas sans casse. Est-ce que quitte à
mettre énormément d'argent, ça valait
pas le coup de prendre les betterraviers
et de les aider à arrêter cette culture
pour laquelle on n'est pas bon, qui est
déficitaire, qui et qu'on exporte dans
des conditions moyennes, qui est hyper
subventionné, c'est ça aurait pas été
plus intelligent de les mettre sur
quelque chose de plus vertueux ? Est-ce
qu'il y a pas un moyen à un moment de
changer le logiciel ? Sinon, on va
continuer à faire du maïs irrigué dans
le sud-ouest. Euh enfin tu vois, je veux
dire c'est il y a un moment si tu veux
bien sûr qu'il va falloir changer des
systèmes parce que si on continue à dire
non mais on sait pas je veux dire on est
dans un système qui fonctionne pas les
mecs sont exangles, ils gagnent pas leur
vie il y a un suicide tous les deux
jours et on continue à mettre du pognon
làdedans.
Malade parce qu'il balancent tout un tas
de salopet.
Bien sûr c'est les premiers vittings des
pesticides. C'est les c'est les
agriculteurs. Ils vivent pas bien ils
sont pas payés. Je veux dire je veux
dire il y a un moment on arrête ou c'est
stop ou c'est encore ? Au moins, c'est
la question que je pose.
Ils sont endettés, ils sont obligés de
faire ça ? Ils sont endettés avec des
machines qui coûtent un bras, ils font
comment ?
Mais alors là où je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi, c'est que c'est on
peut pas leur dire faut changer de
système tout de suite. Là maintenant, je
vous le demande, il faut les
accompagner. Mais enfin, si on met 10
milliards chaque année, on peut pas les
mettre autrement. On peut pas les
accompagner dans un plan ambitieux. Là,
dans les 100 milliards, ils vont mettre
quoi ? Je crois que c'est de mémoire, je
vais peut-être dire une bêtise, c'est 2
milliards 6 qui vont mettre sur sur
l'agriculture verte, c'est-à-dire même
pas enf c'est 10 milliards chaque année
la pâque de de qui on se moque. Tu vois
ce que je viens ? Il y a un moment,
c'est ça l'ambition pour pour changer
l'agriculture française, c'est de mettre
quasiment aucun moyen, pas les aider
effectivement. Et dans ces cas-là, là où
ils ont parfaitement raison, c'est que
si c'est pour les pointer du doigt, les
traiter de gros polluir et être
dégueulasse et pas les aider, ça n'aide
pas parce qu'il faut effectivement ils
sont ils sont dans une situation hyper
compliquée. Moi, je je j'ai j'ai il y a
un mec que j'aime bien qui est devenu
député européen qui s'appelle Benoît
Bito. Il est vert, il est devenu député
européen et c'est un un mec qui fait de
l'agroécologie.
il avait récupéré la la ferme de ses
parents de son père et il disait il y
avait des des kilomètres de de tuyaux
d'irrigation des bâtiments énorme et
cetera et il me dit en fait si tu veux
t'en sortir il faut accepter le fait que
tu ne rentabiliseras pas ça qu'il faut
l'abandonner en fait et repartir d'un
autre sur un autre système. Alors là, on
leur dit pas abandonner ces bâtiments
énormes, abandonner ces ces kilomètres
d'irrigation et cetera. On leur dit "On
va continuer à vous mettre sur perfusion
pour pas que vous creviez tout de
suite."
C'est pas possible ça. Non,
c'est pas non c'est pas Non, ça c'est
ton interprétation mais on les met sous
perfusion pour éviter qu'ils montent à
Paris
parce que dans le dans le top 10 de la
frayeur du CRS, il y a le marin pêcheur,
l'agriculteur.
Bah oui, mais est-ce qu'ils ont ils ont
quand même quelques raisons d'être en
colère, hein, on va pas se mentir.
On passe le bonjour aux marins pêcheurs
et aux agriculteurs. Question
d'internet. Comment expliquer ce dire
non décroissante
et vouloir changer le paradigme actuel ?
A-t-elle une vision biaisée de la
décroissance ? Peut-elle nous dire la
vision qu'elle en a ? Entre parenthèses
et pour ne pas être que négatif, je
salue sa spontanéité et sa parole
franche.
Non mais si tu alors
je vais dissocier décroissance et
collapsologie. Vous avez raison. J'ai
j'ai peut-être fait un amalgame qui
était pas
qui était pas heureux.
La croissance folle dans laquelle on
est, elle n'a aucun sens. Moi, je C'est
vrai que j'échange beaucoup avec Gael
Girot, avec des gens comme ça.
D'ailleurs, Ga Giro passe la semaine
prochaine
et ben vous le saluerez de ma part. Je
trouve que c'est quelqu'un de très
brillant.
Mais pour autant, je crois quand même et
Gael Girou aussi d'ailleurs, je pense
qu'il vous en parlera la semaine
prochaine, qu'il faut pas abandonner
tous nos outils industriels. Je pense
que il faut pas, entre guillemets, se
désarmer. Je pense que il faut pas
abandonner ça. Je pense qu'on peut
transformer l'essai. Je pense que on
peut se lancer dans une très belle
filière hydrogène. Je pense qu'on peut
réfléchir à tout ça. Voilà, c'est tout.
Maintenant euh si vous me dites euh
l'économie aujourd'hui c'est le
capitalisme financier qui broie euh les
salariés euh qui pollue dégueulassement
partout, qui se contrefiche de la
pollution qui l'engendre et qui ne fait
que du fric. Je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous hein. C'est sûr que
c'est une bulle aujourd'hui qui est
complètement déconnectée en fait de la
société et qui n'a plus aucun sens. Pour
autant,
moi j'aimerais au fond que qu'on jette
pas le bébé avec l'eau d'humain. Voilà,
c'est peut-être illusoire, hein.
Peut-être que j'ai tort et peut-être
qu'à la fin, on finira tout ce
collapsologue. Mais j'ai tendance à
penser qu'on peut
on peut trouver un entre deux.
La sobriété.
Oui, mais ça de toute façon, faudra
revenir à un avenir plus sobre. Ça c'est
évident. Ça c'est évident. Vous avez
parfaitement raison. ça a plus aucun
sens tout ça. C'estàd que cette espèce
de consommation dingue pour consommer et
euh et puis pour consommer comment ?
Enfin, je veux dire là,
je suis désolée, je suis en boucle sur
cette histoire de Bridgestone parce
qu'en fait c'est vrai que ça ça m'a
vachement choqué. Mais si tu veux, on
est là à à dire en fait à des gens, vous
faites des pneus trop chers, euh
vous valz pas la peine, euh mais vous
pouvez acheter des des pneus chinois et
puis on va essayer de vous maintenir
plus ou moins au chômage au RSA et euh
enfin c'est pas possible quoi. Ce monde
a plus aucun sens en fait vraiment.
Enfin, je le pense quoi.
Est-ce qu' Est-ce qu'on utilise le C le
CSA le RSA
comme un
filet social pour éviter des émeutes ?
Oui, je pense. Ouais.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'on va se taper
des grosses grosses émeutes avec des
marins pêcheurs et des agriculteurs bien
remontés
qui vont demander la tête de certains ?
Bah, moi je suis très inquiète. En fait,
je trouve que pour le moment, les
Français sont incroyablement calmes et
incroyablement respectueux.
Et mais je suis très inquiète. Je suis
très inquiète parce que les fils
s'allongent que je te disais tout à
l'heure
dans les sous populaires que tu vois
bien que les mecs perdent leur emploi
les uns après les autres, qu'ils ont
peur de le perdre, que tu as des des
familles qui arrivent pas à nourrir
leurs enfants. Donc oui, je suis très
inquiète en fait et je trouve que
l'espèce de nonchalance
communicationnelle à laquelle dont nous
abreuves les politiques me m'angoisse
énormément.
Alors question.
Non, je peux pas passer ça comme
question.
Alors, question simple. Comment on
remplace le nucléaire ?
Ah, mais moi j'ai pas la réponse comme
ça. Je veux pas te dire. En plus, je
suis pas une assez grande spécialiste
des énergies. Je me lancerai pas
là-dedans, ça c'est sûr. Je me lancerai
pas là-dedans chez vous ce soir. J'en
suis pas capable. Mais par contre,
j'aimerais effectivement qu'on se pose
un petit peu la question de tout ce qui
est, si tu veux les éoliennes offshore,
de de se de se lancer là-dedans et de
réfléchir un petit peu à comment on sort
de ce nucléaire parce que je vous dis
pas que j'ai la réponse comme ça, je
l'ai pas. Je serais venu, j'aurais
j'aurais effectivement révisé tous les
trucs de Ngaw avant de venir vous voir
mais je l'ai pas fait donc je vais pas
me lancer dans un truc où je je vais
dire des bêtises. Je préfère je préfère
vous le dire. Tu as étudié le plan de
relance un peu ? Non.
Oui. Alors là, mais moi si tu veux,
c'est le saopudrage. Ça c'est moi c'est
ce que je te disais sur la
l'agriculture. C'est que sur
l'agriculture quand tu vois ce qu'ils
vont mettre, ça va pas. Quand tu vois,
tu vois là par exemple, je discutais
avec un une un mec des services
techniques en région sur la question des
des réformes des lycées. Ils ont dit
voilà, on va mettre 300 millions sur les
lycées. Tu dis 300 millions sur les
lycées, c'est pas mal. Et en fait, il y
a 13 régions. Donc à la fin, si tu veux,
on va se retrouver avec genre 20
millions par région sur les lycées. 20
millions, c'est même pas de quoi
construire un un un lycée, quoi. Donc,
si tu veux, je veux dire et et tu
discutes avec eux, ils disent "Mais nous
dans la rénovation, le machin de truc de
nos de nos lycées, au fond, leur plan
pour les 13 régions, c'est ce qu'on met
par c'est ce qu'on met par an." Donc si
tu veux, c'est pas possible tout ça.
C'est c'est du saupoudrage et après il y
a l'autre truc qui m'angoisse, c'est
qu'ils font comme si ça allait être
déclenché maintenant. Or leur
sous-préfet là hein, déjà ils vont
arriver qu'en janvier. Les trois/4 des
trucs qui nous promettent sur la
rénovation thermique et cetera et
cetera, il y aura besoin de permis de
construire, il y a au moins besoin
d'autorisation en mairie et cetera. Donc
ça c'est un plan à 18 mois. Or, on a
besoin, c'est en urgence qu'on a besoin
de de tout ça. Donc si tu veux, moi ce
qui m'angoisse, c'est ça. Après, quand
tu discutes avec un mec comme Thierry
Mandon, Thierry Mandon, il était il
était ministre à la simplification,
secrétaire d'État, secrétaire d'État à
la fonction publique et à la
simplification sous Hollande.
Il te dit "Mais en fait le problème en
plus c'est comme on aura absolument pas
simplifié les process avant que ça
arrive là où ça doit arriver, mais quand
? Mais quand, tu vois ?" Et là donc
encore une autre personne, une autre
autre autre fonctionnaire de de région
qui me disait en plus il nous avait
promis, Gour nous avait promis en fait
un contrat directement avec nous. Or là
Ber a décidé de reprendre la main et de
faire des appels euh des appels d'offre,
des appels à projet, pardon, des appels
à projet. Et donc qui va répondre aux
appels à projet ? ça va pas être le
petit agriculteur bio à côté de chez
vous, ça va être la FNSA, ça va être les
grands groupes. Donc c'est-à-dire qu'au
fond toutes les petites PME, toutes les
petites boîte, tous ces gens-là
n'arriveront pas à répondre à ces appels
à projet. Donc il y a un moment si c'est
ça n'a pas de sens ce qu'on est en train
de faire.
Une petite question comme ça. Est-ce que
tu as vu que il y avait un sondage qui
était passé sur la peine de mort ? Ah
ouais, ça m'a fait flipper.
Alors
bah ça m'a fait
ça t'a fait flipper parce que tu as pas
vu comment ils avaient posé la question
ou ça t'a fait flipper parce que tu as
vu un grand nombre de personnes répondre
favorablement au retour de la la peine
de mort dans la loi.
Oui. La deuxième option, ça m'a
angoissé.
Ça m'a angoissé. Après, j'ai euh j'ai
discuté avec des spécialistes qui me
disent que le taux est assez stable en
fait. Mais mais j'ai trouvé ça
angoissant. Ouais.
Je pense que ça prouve que au fond
il y a un sentiment d'insécurité inoui
dans ce pays et que
et que soit on est capable d'y répondre
d'une manière ou d'une autre, soit on va
dans un dans un dans un climat qui est
très conflictuel et qui m'angoisse.
Ouais. qui m'angoisse beaucoup.
Question internet. Et Hulo dans tout ça
?
Ouais.
Ben écoute, moi j'ai rien contre l'huile
là.
ni pour ni contre, bien au contraire,
j'ai envie de vous dire, il a essayé, il
a été assez courageux d'aller au
ministère, il a tiré le les conséquence
du fait qu'il arrive à rien faire
là-dedans.
Voilà, moi je trouve que c'est une vraie
personnalité de de l'écologie.
Maintenant Maintenant,
il y aura pas d'homme ou de femme
providentielle là-dedans, quoi. Donc de
toute façon, c'est pas eu l'eau tout
seul avec ses petits bras qui va pouvoir
changer le monde, hein. Ouais, on a
chaud là. On commence à avoir un peu
chaud chez vous. Ouais.
Bon, de toute façon, on arrive bientôt à
la fin de notre
Je vais aller m'occuper de mes petites
fils. Super.
On a souvent une question qui est de
nous conseiller des livres,
trois livres et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Ben moi le vraiment le livre dont je
pense qu'il faut le lire, il va sortir
là incessamment. C'est le livre de Serge
Moran sur le chercheur l'homme la la
faune sauvage et la peste. C'est c'est à
sortir là où c'est c'est moi qui
l'édite. Donc c'est vraiment un bouquin
ça. Normalement on n pas le droit.
Ben d'accord. Alors c'est moi qui
l'édite quand même et c'est pas parce
que je je touche de l'argent dessus.
C'est juste parce que ce chercheur est
juste un mec incroyable. Euh alors donc
si c'est pas des livres que j'ai dites
parce que ce que ce je préfère c'est
ceux que c'est ceux de mes auteurs. Donc
ça va être dur. Alors, qu'est-ce que je
pourrais te proposer comme livre euh
que j'ai euh
C'est horrible parce que tu sais que
c'est un vrai métier en fait, c'est que
je vais chercher les gens que je trouve
les plus pointus dans tous les domaines
et je leur demande de faire un livre qui
est le livre dont j'espère qu'il sera
une arme pour sauver la société. Donc en
fait, j'ai envie de te donner que les
noms de mes de mes auteurs tout en te
disant que ce sont mes auteurs. Donc je
suis en toute transparente. Mais tu
vois, je vais le faire quand même.
Combien, tu prends combien sur tes
auteurs ?
Euh je je prends 2 % sur leur leur
vente. Autant dire que c'est pas avec ça
que je bouffe, on va pas se mentir.
Voilà. Mais
qu'est-ce que tu dis à tes enfants le
soir ?
Qu'il faut continuer à se battre. Qu'il
faut continuer à se battre. Tu vois,
j'ai deux gamines, ces deux guerrières.
Elles sont féministes, elles sont écolo,
elles se battent, elles ont envie de
changer le monde et quand je les vois,
je me dis qu'on peut pas baisser les
bras. Voilà, moi je dis qu'il faut se
battre mais j'ai pas un truc de bisous
nours, hein. Je dis pas c'est cool, ça
va bien se passer.
Un troisème bouquin. Alors
donc je t'ai dit quoi ? Je t'ai dit
Serge Morand. Je t'ai dit euh du coup
j'en ai dit qu'un. Non. Le 2è c'est
c'est ce sera celui de de Gemen,
François Gemen, on a tous un ami noir,
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure sur
l'immigration parce que je pense c'est
un livre très très important et euh un
bouquin que j'ai pas édité du coup.
Alors qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire ?
Je sais pas, je sais pas
qu'est-ce que je qu'est-ce qui me
qu'est-ce qui m'a troublé ces derniers
moments, ces derniers temps.
Je pense à des romans, mais des vieux
romans. Donc si tu veux, je peux pas
dire des trucs, tu vois. J'ai des idées
de de romans de de de
Quel est le dernier livre qui t'a fait
pleurer ? Quel est le dernier auteur qui
t'a fait pleurer ?
Moi je moi j'adore j'ai un livre que
j'adore qui qui va me faire passer pour
un énorme névrosé, c'est la promesse de
l'aube de de Romain Gary sur sur sa
relation un petit peu pathologique avec
sa mère. C'est ça. Je pense que c'est un
des livres que j'aime le plus. Moi là où
j'ai un sujet, c'est que quand j'aime un
livre, je le relis 15 fois. Donc si tu
veux, je suis une grande je suis une
grande adoratrice de pro. Je pense que
j'ai lu la recherche une vingtaine de
fois. J'adore. Et quand je suis au fin
fond de la dépression, ce qui était le
cas pendant le Covid, je relisais
l'agonie de sa grand-mère, ce qui était
forcément pas forcément le moment. Et
quand j'ai vu que l'ançon faisait pareil
quand il se faisait opérer, le pauvre
après les attentats, je me suis dit que
ça doit être un truc quand tu es en
semi-dépression. Donc j'ai j'aime relire
les classiques en fait. C'est quelque
chose qui qui m'apaise et qui me
rassure. J'aime lire les correspondances
aussi des grands des grands auteurs.
J'ai j'ai adoré lire la correspondance
de Flobert. Euh j'adore lire euh la la
correspondance de Camu. Je je j'adore
lire ces correspondances de ces de ces
gens parce que d'abord euh ils sont
beaucoup plus intelligents que moi et en
plus euh parce que tu te rends compte
qu'ils ont aussi des préoccupations
triviales. Euh je veux dire Flobert, il
l' décrit beaucoup mieux que nous mais
il a ses quand ses lettres avec Louis
Colet
donc c'est sa maîtresse il raconte voilà
il la il essaie de la conquérir et
parfois il est très trivial et j'aime ça
en fait. Donc voilà, je tu vois, je
serais pas capable en fait de te de te
sortir euh de te sortir un autre auteur
comme ça.
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations,
il faut se battre. Mais ils se battent
déjà
comment ? Mais
il faut se battre comme ils le font
déjà. Ils ont pas besoin de moi les
jeunes générations. Tu as vu comme ils
sont partis dans la rue pour faire les
Friday euh Friday for Climat ? Friday
for quoi déjà ? C'était Friday fort
Future, je me souviens plus le truc
lancé par Gretenberg. Moi, je pense
qu'ils se battent déjà les jeunes. J'ai
rien à leur dire. Ils savent déjà. Ils
ils sont c'est des guerriers, c'est des
guerriers écolo d'ailleurs souvent et
ils ont envie de changer le monde et et
ils ont pas un peu trop en train de se
radicaliser là.
C'est normal qu'il se radicalis, c'est
tu as vu le merdier qu'on leur laisse ?
Enfin, je veux dire soit on est à la
hauteur et c'est là que j'entends aussi
les gens qui sont sur sur ta chaîne,
soit on est à la hauteur, tu vois, et à
ce moment-là, ils auront pas besoin de
se radicaliser, soit c'est pas le cas.
Et bien sûr qu'on va aller vers des mais
mais partout on va aller vers des
actions radicales. C'est pour ça que les
politiques, il faut vraiment qu'il se
qu'il se bouge.
Isabelle Spporta. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]